avec avec un petit intérêt pour nous ce
soir avec un petit intérêt puisque notre
notre favori bons joueurs qu'on va
supporter dans la compétition rentrer en
jeu il rentre en jeu aujourd'hui on
espère bien qu'il aille qu'il aille au
bout et on espère bien qu'il aille au
bout donc c'est notre c'est notre
poulain qui va affronter qui va
affronter km/heure jeune allemand
talentueux mais on se frotte les doigts
de cet affrontement
on est confiant pour pour ce premier
match premier tour ça devrait ça devrait
être tranquille en franchement on
devrait gagner sans forcer à mon avis on
n'a pas forcé notre talent notre joueur
m'inspire la confiance je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas inquiet devrait ça devrait
ça devrait passer même si même si
km/heure et dangereux en blitz
mais bon ça devrait ça devrait passer
comme une lettre à la poste
ils sont ils sont cadres un peu
différemment dire j'avais pensé qu'on
avait fait deux premiers réglages que ça
allait j'ai mis les caméras mais où ils
sont pas papa en face de la même manière
qu hier donc le réglage le regard j'ai
refait salua sefyu 30 frigui freaky
frogs bundy fr alors attendez on a on a
un jeu l'impression qu'on a tout bon je
vais vérifier
je vais vérifier ça tranquillement
tant d un homme on va vérifier ça
tranquillement la suède dans le chat en
fait c'est que c'est bon en soi mais ah
non mais c'est pas possible c'est witch
qui dit qu' aucune chaîne d'échec un tac
tac tac
pourquoi est ce que je la vois pas en
ligne ça doit être une erreur ouais non
non elle est en ligne allait on line
cnra avec twitch qui me fait suer
on est bel et bien là salua ben 68 668
230 froid je veux repartir en chine mais
pour l'arménie quand on est toujours à
fond pour les gens armés le match qui a
commencé d'ailleurs pendant que je me
promets une petit bug twitch bien sûr
bien sûr c'est pas sûr qu'il ya une la
compétition mais je m'attends pas à un
match serré où on m'a vendu sa chasse
comme ils m'ont dit ouais ça va être un
match serré aujourd'hui et tout match
match très très serré en perspective
franchement moi une cote à 1 20 je
prends je vais la maison dessus je mets
la maison sur une cote à 1 20 et ils
m'ont vendu ça comme un match ultra
serré écoute pour le moment il n'y a pas
encore eu de match vraiment serré il ya
eu celui d'hier mais bon c'est quand
même ce evian
le score est moins sévère que ça aurait
pu être il a vraiment été en contrôle
tout le match et quand il a vraiment
voulu accélérer il a fait très très mal
jusqu'à maintenant que que des matchs à
sens unique et je vois pas un autre
scénario pour le match d'aujourd'hui
même si vincent km/heure et dangereux
mais mon contre martirossian je ne vois
pas je ne vois pas faire du service en
juillet j'ai un excellent ratio sur les
speechs s je n'y a que duda qui m'avait
surpris deux fois
et c'était quoi est sur duda une saison
mais sinon j'ai rangé du quasi 100% sur
les sur les speechs s je suis je suis un
monstre de d'anticipation sur ces
matches donc là c'est c'est une variante
de moscou un qu'on a déjà pu voir hier
avec le fou prend m6 et martirossian qui
retarde un peu le 4 qui prépare un peu
le bk qui veut jouer contre le fu c8
vous allez vous allez voir ça va y avoir
des petits bijoux de martirossian en
même temps vu la durée on est plutôt sur
du résultat bas après oui là faut dire
sefyu pour la peine que l'objectif
d'être bien sûr du résultat il est il
est complètement rempli par la cadence
c'est vrai que c'est le point positif
sans eau sans rigoler or complètement
complètement premier degré sans second
degré du tout pour la peine c'est vrai
que le l'objectif de de voir des matches
si l'on sait d'être bien sûr que ce soit
le meilleur qui le remporte et laisser
minimum de place au hasard et c'est vrai
que c'est ce qui nous plaît pas entre
guillemets mais mais le le contrat est
rempli le contrat est rempli et c'est
vrai qu'il ya et il ya très très très
peu de surprises et vraiment c'est un
joueur
et plus fort que son adversaire tu
rentres tu rentres vraiment as tu
rentres vraiment sûr sur du 95,5 même
même si l'écart n'est pas si grand quoi
hélas pour moi l'écart sera grandmont
verra avant 100 km heure sera bien
préparé il fait 10 réussi à faire le
b565 c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
bref vous avez créé la surprise et a
deux dents est exactement il en avait
créé deux d'ailleurs sefyu si tu te
rappelles bien il avait créé deux
surprises c'est à dire qu'en fait quand
tu crées une surprise c'est que tu es
plus fort qu'on le pensait
en fait tu peux pas créé de surprise si
t'as pas le niveau c'est le c'est
l'enseignement que j'avais tiré de
l'épisode duda c'est qu'en fait une
première surprise en appel une deuxième
c'était contre gries choo qui l'avait
battue non il avait battu great choc car
jaeckin et il avait perdu contre sow
dans un match serré mais il est vrai
qu'une surprise en appelle une autre
parce qu'en fait tu peux pas faire de
surprises ouais le match vient de
commencer attendez j'ai pas mis le
chrono je suis pas encore habitué avec
ce chrono je rappelle jamais du nom du
programme
c'est nouveau que je sache mettre des
chronos et il doit rester on va on va se
mettre bien
de rester une heure 24 on va se mettre
le chronomètre 25
ouais du coup après c'est plus une
surprise comme on dit ah ouais c'est
vrai que c'est une surprise la première
fois et la deuxième fois en fait il faut
te dire il faut il faut réévaluer le
niveau du joueur en fait et se dire
qu'il est plus fort que prévu
fête a été surpris par son niveau quoi
mais il n'a pas forcément gagné contre
le cours du jeu même si je pense qu en
s'habituant cariat qui n'était plus fort
et great choc aussi mais ils n'ont pas
réussi à il avait un style de jeu
particulier vraiment fort en ait note je
pense sur un vrai chic et sur un même
format et se serait fait massacrer mais
il était vraiment très fort dans les
dents les ait note
moi je crois c'est pour éviter fou g4
est bien installé le pion aux 5
je dois dire dans ce début de match
enfin dans cette première partie en tout
cas km/heure sort vraiment bien
l'ouverture
je vous rappelle que son entraîneur
c'est peter l'écho ouais le chinois qui
avait battu qui est battue m'a ému sans
en coupe du monde après moi je trouve
que le charme des matchs et des tournois
et du sport en général c'est qu'ils
aient des surprises mais après ça c'est
un goût personnel une nouvelle fois mais
là c'est vrai que je vois je vois je
vois me quitte à riom vraiment beaucoup
plus fort et donc je ne vois pas de
surprise il ya une trop grosse
différence de niveau tu vas faut qu'ils
aient moins de 50 points de chaises
comme pour que la surprise soit possible
pour moi pour que le joueur le moins
fort et une chance de l'emporter
aux échecs n'a pas le même problème que
dans d'autres sports en plus où tu peux
avoir une petite blessure ou un petit
truc en fait tu vas jamais trop perdre
de niveau sur des formats comme ça
après comme je vous dis ça fait cesser
le rôle que soit remplir le format donc
il le remplit bien connu qu'il ya des
jours on voit rien pour des joueurs de
ce niveau là c'est très rare franchement
regardez même mois on va apprendre mon
exemple à la con même les jours où je
stream crever ou j'ai fait des semaines
et des semaines de stream non-stop sans
arrêt que je suis dans un mauvais jour
que je suis un peu malade ou quoi c'est
rare que je descende en dessous de 2006
vrai ou faux
c'est très rare que je suis en dessous
de 2006 même crevé après neuf heures de
stream complètement défoncée de deux
semaines où j'ai travaillé 13 14 heures
la veille et le jour même
ça m'est déjà arrivé et malgré ça je
vais maintenir entre 26 et 26 50
et pourtant je vous assure que ces jours
là j'ai vraiment le cerveau qui marchent
plus l'escale jeunes français qui
participent à la compétition non franck
franck donc c'est pour vous dire qu aux
échecs en fait à partir d'un certain
niveau la fluctuation et l'oat les
pluies si énorme ont réussi à bien gérer
à savoir jouer quand on calcule moins
vite en fait on change un peu notre
manière de jouer et ça passe
et donc une différence lots de 200
points sur sur des matches comme ça
paraît rédhibitoire quoi après peut-être
gamer il joue plutôt à 2900 mais à mon
avis à bien sans point entre les deux
alors cette finale elle doit être mieux
pour les noirs parce que je sur desalle
est fou compte cavaliers mais ça doit
être nul
les mines qui en d4 ils ont qu'à la
joueurs km heure il est très jeune
édouard 15 ans et high qui doit avoir 21
je pense qu'il faut faire droit à 8,3
17e' six cavaliers ils veulent sortir
comment en fait à roye 17 il veut qu a
et b 8 d'accor et cavaliers prendra six
mairies que qu'est vraiment un excellent
médecin
c'est vraiment un très bon joueur ce
jour arménien pour la peine et je pense
je pense pas c'est pas forcément un
castor des îles assez bien joué de la
part de km heure il veut jouer car il y
prend assise food et 4 mai bond car il y
va venir en c2 il va bloquer ces il va
protéger arrive à bloquer b il va aller
jouer de l'autre côté il va aller
chercher la nulle part cette affaire qui
est b4y ces deux en fait
vous allez faire une vidéo avant la
reprise des candidats avec fap peut vous
avez fait pour la première partie en
fait le truc c'est qu'on a déjà tout dit
pour la première partie donc je pense
pas qu'on refasse la même on en fera
peut-être une pour rappeler un peu les
enjeux le classement les appariements
les machins mais je pense pas qu'on
refasse une partie par joueur bah ça a
déjà été fait ça ferait double emploi il
est tombé à incroyable c'était vraiment
nul de chez nul quoi y avait juste à
faire droit aux 6 il ya eu quoi il ya eu
des connexions il s'est passé quoi je je
je faisais plus attention je regardais
le chat parce que c'était vraiment nul
de chez nul là on y avait il y avait
plus de matériel sur l'échiquier quoi
juste 3 o6 et tu es assez fou prend 1,5
et ça allait faire nul tout seul quoi je
pense qu'ils aient des cartes et chèques
fou prend des quatre nuls mais un peu
importe mais un peu étonné la queue qui
soit tombé c'est ça ce n'est vraiment
tout seul en fait c'est plutôt lui d'air
qui jouait pour gagner un peu toulon
quoi il avait bien joué c'est un peu
inquiétant oreilles la zapper la pendule
way
avec la incrémentale était vraiment
évidente 1 il a juste juste oublié la
pendule moi je me suis mouillé sur ce
matin sur twitter en donnant
martirossian grand favori donc il me
faut il faut il faut une victoire
convaincante
je vais tenter à et le 100% va être dur
mais je vais je vais essayer de
pronostiquer un maximum de match
correctement je serai fier de faire un
100 %
donc ces petites positions solides
dwight indienne avec lecavalier 6 qui
tient bien la baraque se passe plutôt
bien pour pour notre poulain après il y
aura des matches le que les quarts de
finale seront plus intéressants mouais
genre martirossian par am c'est un beau
match déjà là le format plus long fait
fait plus sens en fait c'est vrai quand
il jouera contre martirossian parent
martirossian sevian martirossian ou là
ce sera plus intéressant déjà là on est
toujours sur le premier tour maugrée fu
lei est-ce que ça va être regardable à
partir des quarts de finale on va avoir
des beaux chocs
là normalement c'est encore un match à
sens unique
mais là ça semble bien se passer pour
les blancs quand même
f5 ça fait mal hein
à plusieurs personnes qui se sont
plaints que je j'ai dit des spectateurs
je veux dire que les matches et plus peu
d'intérêt après le truc c'est que j'ai
raison donc c'est un c'est un autre
problème
ça n'empêchera pas de le dire le truc
c'est qu'après quand je dis que les
matches ont de l'intérêt
vous savez que je mens pas c'est
l'avantagé d'être sincère en fait rêver
avoir un tour pour à mon avis un tour
pro f 6 et cavaliers prend des cinq ici
davantage c'est comme envoyer à tout
retour ici aussi c'est quand je dis que
ça va être bien généralement c'est bien
ouais bah après moi j'aime pas trop un
con c'est comme une étape de plat du
tour de france où tu vas te prendre 180
kilomètres de plat et tu sais qu'il va y
avoir un sprint au final et que tu es là
à dire il ya de leitza il va se passer
quelque chose
non il va rien se passer alors 180 km tu
peut allumer tu as ta télé à un
kilomètre et demi de la fin tu as pas
perdu de temps quoi donc
quand les matches quand les matches sont
comme ça quand j'imagine des scénarios
comme ça je préfère vous le dire après
ce que je vous dis un spa du 100 % 1
j'aurais raison 95 fois sur 100 de temps
en temps il va se passer quelque chose
ce qu'on espère à chaque fois d'ailleurs
j'espère me tromper bas sauf aujourd'hui
parce que je veux vraiment que là on a
d'autres joueurs là on a notre
martirossian donc là c'est le poulain
qui doit gagner c'est différent
tu as vu qu'avec eux karlsson a gagné
conjointement et qui croient ils ont ils
ont en fait il donnait en cas en cas de
en cas de co vainqueur il donnait deux
médailles d'or depuis quand on supporte
l'arménie mais toujours à bobby fischer
2 1 toujours en son supporter les
joueurs arménien à fond d'ailleurs ça
allait bien quand la prod classique va
reprendre avec les quarts de finale et
tout ça on va pouvoir re supporter les
demi finales on va de nouveau être pour
l'équipe d'arménie de partout bien sûr
on supporte l'arménie pas de bluff 6 6 1
on l'a par contre peut pas faire une
cave et d5 intermédiaire un truc c'est
pas j'aime pas trop la structure j'aime
pas trop l'activité des pièces c'est la
mode déco victoire pourquoi pourquoi ces
hypocrites sais pas c'est pas hypocrite
on est on est du côté des meilleurs 1
on est avec les meilleurs m'abaisser
volet truc de deux candidats deux
victoires de deux vainqueurs puisque sur
sur le papier avec le départage habituel
c'est anna carin qui a gagné le tournoi
mais bon ça devait être dans leurs
règles que en cas d'égalité il ya deux
vainqueurs quoi c'est beau dommage ça
aurait pu faire un départage sympa on
dise plus sain qu'un petit match et tout
ça aurait pu être cool quand même
surtout le vu le prize pool qui est
engagée on aurait pu avoir un duel
intéressant entre les deux hommes
c'est dommage
mais à faire quoi faire vous prend
réussir la tour qui va arriver en 17 ans
allez ce qu'il va faire à 5 avec l'idée
sur qui les prend à 5 tours à huit way
allez il a défoncé la note micky mais ça
lui cyril off
ouaip à deux pas des partages bas c'est
dommage qu'ils aient pas eu de départage
au delà au delà au delà a levé qu'à
d'inde en départage tiens c'est
martirossian à crolles à la wes arrêt
série lost merci la grippe à des
partages
ouais c'est dommage qu'ils aient pas
joué un match de départage à la rigueur
parce que c'est vrai que ça aurait pu
être agréable à suivre
ça aurait pu être agréable à suivre un
match de départager c'est vrai que ça
aurait pu être un peu le moment
intéressant du tournoi qu'on attendait
tous et puis nous ont ils nous ont
privés de ça c'est dommage mais bon
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
bon la question ici c'est ce que le pion
aux va être un danger ou pas ce qu'on va
perdre b3 ça c'est sûr mais on a eu qui
va partir et peut-être même h en fait vu
qui l'a fait roi m6 mais méailles qu'il
est vraiment vraiment très fort c'est un
excellent mitzach blague à part on
propose 3 f 3 tours prend et qu'elle
prend à 5
weaver au retour à troyes toutes façons
caresser 4.4 et les noirs vont avoir
leur contre eux jeu mais oui pour preuve
cette ça doit être bien il ya deux pions
plus quand même et le carré les ans et 4
me paraît fort c'est la partie justement
mais le pion à eux va être fort
on va le voir on va le voir arriver ce
pur eux mais l'option h les deux pions
qui vont être violent d'ailleurs fou
c'est pour essayer d' un peu bloqué
peut-être l'avancé des pions alors il
veut il veut essayer de créer des
pseudos menace sur le roi alors c'est
malin dans le sens où il est vraiment
mal
il sait que si la partie continue son
fleuve sont ruissellement tranquille il
va la perdre
donc il décide de tenter de changer les
choses et la part de 3,5 me lasserai
maths en un alors bon ok il y aurait
toujours eu qu'à toucher 4 mais c'est
pour dire que les noirs réussissent à
créer une menace à et son idée c'est que
sur e4 e5 il aura des idées de tours à 3
tours angers 3 c'est bien joué au roi m
5 est sûre j'ai quatre rois e5 ouais ça
c'est très bien jouer dehors provoqué 4
ce qui était quand même pour moi contre
logique mais il a réussi à comprendre ça
très vite et maintenant tour à trois il
va gagner le pion g3 et quand tu gagnes
g3 ça change tout en fait alors attendez
encore roy eu deux amis vais avoir tout
re trois fous pranger 3 je pense qu'il
va faire un échec intermédiaire quand il
prend direct du coup ils attaquent le
cavalier qui étrangers si ces quatre
essais avec le pion à le pion noirs
commencent à avancer
alors est ce qu'on fait h5 ces 3 h 6 et
2 h cette c1 et dames sur échec
donc on peut être tenté d'envoyer le
pion d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait donc
quand tu arrives en h7 il faudrait
intervenir partout à 8 et c'est
important que les blancs n'est pas tour
c'est 8 parce qu'il ya fou prend il ya
le fou qui contrôle bon alors là il va y
avoir peut-être savoir échec échec
attention à 20 100 km/heure en sueur à
il est en train de subir la loi du
joueur arménien fouet f2 ici pour fou et
roi fou prend h6 entourage d'autray
jouer aussi roy prend le cas donc il
récupère un lion il va aller vers ces 4
après trois des trois rois des quatre
aux irois dkt roi c4 t'as plus d'échec
il a il a chopé le pion au passage et
ils menacent ils menacent tout reprend
h5 bêtement roi b3 maintenant il n'ya
pas d'échec en b 8
c'est fini finito ces deux c1 dégage
et oui et oui mon petit vincent 2 0
c'est pas la même ligue en face ce n'est
pas la même ligue
vincent km/heure qui tombe contre plus
fort que lui ouais j'ai mis mon petit
tweet avant je me suis dit est ce que je
vais me faire car ns way martirosyan et
battu à une veille dans un title tuesday
en quarts de finale ou en demi finale je
crois en car c'est un sacré morceau 1 et
attention attention à 20 100 km heure ça
ça peut ça peut ça peut aller très très
vite contre contre martirossian gamers
oseo exactement la ccl km/heure sauce
est là là il s'est fait sauter les amis
il est dans le jus km heure allez bon
lait tombé à il est tombé contre un des
gros favoris de la compet
il est tombé contre un des gros favoris
de la compet
et ça va lui faire très très mal il va
comprendre ce qu'il sépare du haut
niveau oui c'est notre joueur là qui qui
fait mal hein
merci à julien garrigues pour les beats
en tout cas ça se passe plutôt bien pour
le moment le pion aux 5 il faut vraiment
jouer ces cinq je pense pour les noirs
ici et pas à laisser le temps de se
faire vis et si ce cavalier arrive sur
ces cinq ouhlala fouka tour c'est un
lacet thématique ça peut faire très mal
si on réussit à vis et le fion sur ces
six les noirs devons jamais sortir il va
être enfermé à vitam aeternam donc
temps des huit tours c1
bah écoutes je vais faire un tube faire
un dix hommes avait un contrat mvele bah
écoute go faire un budget un ça va te
coûter le prix d'une bitstream capin je
te préviens tout de suite pour faire une
suite un à dix contre mvl c'est pas
c'est surtout que ça c'est cool pour les
17 qui seront sélectionnés mais en gros
ils vont juste se faire défoncer 10-0
quoi ouais tour c1 et cavaliers ses cinq
essais mort qui est des deux qui a et b
3 il va falloir mettre le cavaly va
attaquer le pion à 5 et va jouer la
casse c5 et pourra même reprendre de la
tour ah non il va il va gagner
facilement pourquoi ces chars comme ça
ouais bah oui surtout que c'est pas
quelque chose d'agréable à faire pour
maxime quand c'est quelque chose de
marrant ce quelque chose de marrant mais
ça c'est juste chiant à faire en fait
les simultanée c'est juste chiant
c'est juste très chiant à jouer c'est
chiant à regarder mission contre quoi
j'en ai déjà fait des simultanée c'est
absolument inintéressant que ce soit
pour moi ou pour les spectateurs
ces juges sur en fait
ouais là le pion c6 ses serments le
mauvais truc hein quand le pion ce fait
fut bissé ans et six dans ces structures
type slave
je vous dis toujours que c'est ce qu'on
veut absolument éviter c'est pour ça que
vous voyez toujours tenté de faire ces
cinq quoi qu'il en soit et il a du coup
le quart eli va arriver en c5 l'un ou
l'autre
un jour peut-être maintenant peut-être
dans dix coups mais de toute façon le le
pion c6 sévices et on pourra le manger
quand on voudra y a cinq qui est qui est
faible il ya les casses b6 et 5 il ya
même la casse des six il ya tout pour
les blancs martirossian qui en plus a
joué très vite ça va probablement faire
3 0 et on peut on peut on peut peut-être
assister à une adoption
alors tour à sète qui a et b c5 qui peut
arriver
alors pourquoi plutôt le b peut-être
cieux cavaliers à il s'active avec un
kata 5 vous êtes maître ce cavalier on
provoque un échange on reprend la tour
on va mettre le touriste y et prendre
ses 6 alors il aura quand même l'idée de
faire flouer fuite pour chasser donc
après il faut il faut calculer voir si a
pas encore plus fort peut-être juste
tour ces deux tours c'est un est aussi
une option 1
il ya fou prend ses six aussi à regarder
d'ailleurs que j'ai oublié tellement n'a
envie de garder ce four murray
donc il faut penser 6
salut de chasse nous faisons ce par
match en dix points mais si tu gagnes
10-0 tu fais une adoption
donc ça ça peut être intéressant gagné
10 0 peut être intéressant sera mené
10-0 peut enfin mettre dix parties
d'affilée peut être intéressante une
adoption
ok donc il a pris le pion ça vaut des
points en plus tous a conclu le match
annonce ça sert à rien ça veut dire que
tu a adopté le gars donc l'adoption ça
consiste en maître on met à gagner un
moment donné dix parties d'affilée
contre un joueur tu l'adoptent ce qui ne
sert à rien mais ce qui donne un peu
d'enjeu pour le public dans des matchs à
sens unique
ça montre un peu ta supériorité par
rapport à l'adversaire quoi donc sur
dame c'est cette île va bêtement jouer
qui prend à 8 et il va voir le pion de
plus mais qui peut peut-être qu'ils ne
va peut-être pas réussir à conserver
malheureusement trois essais pour flex
en gros exactement
mais là malheureusement il s'est
peut-être précipité sur le pion c6 c'est
une humiliation on peut appeler ça aussi
une humiliation mais on appelle ça une
adoption mais en gros c'est le même
principe que l'humiliation et surtour
des inquiets le coup qu'on veut faire
dame prend 1,5 ta du g3 on temporise et
après on fait tour 17,2 g iii c'est pour
éviter de se prendre demain matin et
après on rentre c'est peut-être ça
l'idée de die qu'il a fait cavalier de
d4 il faut prendre 5 il doit voir
cavaler b5 et c7 peut-être quelque chose
comme ça
allez on va lui faire confiance kemmer
fut la technique du roseau web après
comme comme on a on en a déjà parlé hier
à une fois que tu as cinq points
d'avance le match est vraiment quasi
plié
donc il doit vraiment revenir rapidement
au score 6 paires celle là la prochaine
encore la prochaine il peut très vite
fin j ça parce qu'en fait talata les
noirs
tu es très mal la prochaine du coup
c'est avec eux qui peut peut-être vrai
qu'avec les noirs et après il reprend
les blancs donc ça peut aller très vite
y perdre une vente marrante
est ce que dame k tour des huit tours
c'est un tour prend des cadres dame
prend des cada me prends des quatre c7
et la dame est imparable ans et 8
il a fait dans le cadre d'ailleurs ça
doit être l'idée de ce2 martirossian non
il fait cavalier f3 faut et puis tu vas
mettre la tour en c1 j'imagine après il
peut commencer par h4 en se disant que
de toute façon les matchs du couloir
doivent être empêché et h4 peut préparer
h5 en tout cas donné une case h2 pour le
roi donc le kw/h 4 pour partie rossillon
ici est complètement envisageable
qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir d'autres
d'un f4 non puisque adam français six
tours c1
pourquoi pas sur dame prend reprendre la
dame on laisse pas de maths du couloir
j'ai trois ans j'aurais plutôt fait h41
dans le même style mais bon j'ai trois
tours 2-3 j'ai deux tours ces deux mais
alors là le problème c'est qu'ils se
fait entourer le pion c6 qui peut plus
défendre c'est très bien joué de la part
de gamer qui a réussi à retourner cette
partie mais il n'y aura pas deux il y
aura pas l'adoption n'allait h4
3g 2 h 5 lames f4 peut-être pour ses
deux oreilles veut il veut pas il veut
pas aller c'est la diagonale alive
autour des 1
ça peut être dangereux la dame f4e 4k
relief si ça va être le plan alors il
laisse ce pion il va faire quoi carré
lieu 4 x 6 cavaliers fou j'ai sept
cavaliers 6 ou peut-être tour c'est 8
arrive à jouer pour ces huit dames ses
huit des 27 tours s'est vite ces trucs
heures comme coût pour ces huit avec
très peu de temps c'est hyper chiant lc1
coups de beats r ça
il a joué avec 0,01 heaulme arles où il
va faire tour des huit ici coup de
marloux temps des 8 est un gros coup de
marloux de martirossian dame prend des
huit qu'adam premier set il ya damas
huit aussi qui est intéressant mais
damas huit et adam des cinq breaks tour
des huit c'est un coup de marloux dam
des huit dames fc est allé va le voir
aller aie aie fait il fait autour des
huit coups de marloux où il joue avec 0
0 mais c'est incroyable et maintenant
tour huit dames c5 qui fait cavalier e 4
tours e8 à il ya plus de bonnes cases
pour la dame et pour prend et touré
cheikh touré chaque et matt hall marlou
il a joué avec 0 0 c'est incroyable je
n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un jouer avec 0
secondes
j'avais jamais vu quelqu'un rester en
vie 100 ans en tout cas ça fait 3 r
ça fait 3 r le score qui enfle je vous
avais dit 1 km heure je prenais le
handicap sur twitter avec grande
confiance et ça re joue encore une
variante de moscou martirossian est
juste plus fort hein
il est juste plus fort et le score qui
enfle au déjà un 3 0 après trois parties
et on a pas on n'a pas vu de signes
annonciateurs d'un retour un du joueur
allemand qui semble juste ne pas boxer
dans la même catégorie
ça me fait penser on a fait venir un
poids plume contre un poids welters
contre 1 toutes catégories mais ça va
pas durer très longtemps
est-ce que l'indien potentiel de table
10 nitoo c'est déjà un peu tard alors
martirossian c'est déjà beaucoup trop
tard km heure il a le potentiel mais j'y
crois pas du tout moi j'y crois pas du
tout donc martirossian clairement non km
heure soit disant oui mais je vous dis
non pas la même catégorie d'âge aussi à
ce que je disais un an ce premier tour
il ya d'énormes disparités en termes de
niveau de jeu
c'est un petit peu dommage quoi
qui est le futur magnus carlsen on sait
pas comment comment dire à 6 ans c'est
exactement la même question tu pourras
la pause et dans n'importe quel sport
quel est le jeune de 6 ans qui deviendra
pro personne le sait en fait c'est
impossible
tu vois qui dans le top 10 mondial je
sais pas mais on a pas beaucoup qui
rentreront les anciens ils vont rester
pendant un moment encore du coup dans
les nouvelles générations sur mon fil
rouge a peut-être bouquet chopra ganda
peut-être les deux peut-être sarine
abdou s'auto rohff mes murs facile crois
pas trop
on a eu de la nature et à sion fut
rogers dans la question est posée un peu
tous les jours quand on sait pas mais
normalement il faut avoir au moins deux
ans de vie sur le territoire français ce
n'est pas encore le cas
je connais des jeunes de 6 ans qui
seront jamais pro de quoi que ce soit
par contre c'est plus facile à prévoir
ceux qui réussiront pareil il l'aurait
dit devient quand on le voit plus trop
bas et koutiala confinement pour tout le
monde donc comme comme tous les autres
joueurs il est il peut pas participer à
des farc quoi qu'il ya des tours est en
réelle qui ont repris mais évidemment sa
participation au tournoi a été affectée
par par le cos vie de parent lakovic 19
d'ailleurs comme un peu tout le monde a
envie de dire
on verra on verra comment ça évolue
mais toi qui ont repris mais très peu et
puis après est-ce que tu as vraiment
envie d'aller jouer c'est une autre
question que tu as envie d'être govinden
ou pas bon après la maintenant lé tour
vont reprendre un tronc à chartres j'ai
vu ça avec des possibles normes de grand
maître
il va il va y avoir aussi normalement le
norwich est qui va reprendre
il ya des choses il ya des choses qui
sont prévues oui effectivement
en tout cas je suis très content du
scénario de ce match là pour le moment
notre joueur qui met une énorme pression
notre joueur qui marche sur l'adversaire
alors leurs lots c'est 3031 pour mikit
arian et 2008 121 pour gamer différence
énorme et qu'émerge est dit il doit
avoir 15 ans qui mérite d'avoir 15 ans
maintenant
en tout cas ce match qui se passe bien
je regardais juste un truc qui
m'étonnait je vois que les les portugais
ont jeté l'épongé
ni portillon jeter l'épongé du
commentaire c'est ont jeté l'épongé dans
cette compétition moi je raterais
l'eponge ce week-end sur un match
vendredi et samedi dimanche
je ferai une petite pause là ça fait
quatre week-ends que je commande
d'affilée je vais aussi jeté l éponge
c'est sûr que ils ont ils ont dû sentir
le match à sens unique un oui et il va
faire a4 a3 je pense la tour en a cinq
pions b5 va être favori il a réussi à
échanger son fou de cases blanches 1 me
qui le pion qui arrivant à trois pions
b5 sous pression de pions des quatre
sous pression le pion à 3 est un monstre
ça pourrait faire 4-0
elle a peut-être un tour à cinq tours à
huit ici am il veut peut-être empêché
des cinq ans peut-être faut faire qui a
aidé 5 dans ces cas là
toi intéressant il blogue g5 samedi et
dimanche c'est le début des quarts andy
boxe c'est pas le début des quarts
samedi et dimanche
terrible les fêtes news dans le chat les
amis et puis bon quand bien même ce
serait le début des quarts même si c'est
pas le cas
un moment donné il faut aussi un peu se
reposer c'est pas possible tous les
jours de bosser 10 heures comme ça sept
jours par semaine et un moment donné
l'organisme demande du repos qui va
échanger changé mais atteint une impasse
prendre un truc en 17 c'est dangereux
mais il doit vouloir jouer sur son pion
à 3 on est lundi reste quatre matches
pour les huitièmes a donc ça joue demain
tu as des infos au xix boxe j'avais pas
clair un match demain si tu avais
j'étais pas au courant ni mercredi ni
jeudi d'ailleurs tu as tu eu des échos
pour des 8,3 g7
il veut prendre en b 5 ouais c'est un
peu dangereux mais ils en maîtrisent en
fait son pion à 3 est trop fort
ben je passe tu avais eu des échos d-box
mais l'art sûr de toi
si l'écho qui suivrait non mais vraiment
le match qu'on a sur le papier était
complètement déséquilibré un alors dams
est non puisque dame saturé tour 17
si j'avais fait un peu saturé tour
d'essai ty faire une double attaque mais
la dame prend 2,5 tu vas protéger et tu
vas gagner déjà un premier pion à l'est
le 4 0 qui en route les amis qui title
ses deux mains seront normalement avec
mazet normalement avec le capitaine
mazet capitaine mazet les amis attention
parce qu'en plus ce nom il ya des matchs
du couloir les menaces se multiplient
pour le joueur arménien l'allemand sueur
et encore b5 qui va tomber et sur
cavaliers prend tout reprendra me prends
à 3 y aura tourbe et un attaque de maths
elle va se prendre cavaliers des quatre
maintenant ça va aller très très vite
c'est chose faite
il va devoir tenter dame c4 pour
maintenir son pion en vie et bonne
chance pour défendre le roi s'est passé
qui avaient lieu deux tours c'est simple
le plus efficace mais ça semble faire
très mal
début de match compliqué hein pour
vincent km/heure début de match
extrêmement compliquée pour le joueur
allemand qui n'a pas réussi encore
empocher la moindre nul d'amiens saddam
4 je pense est maintenant tourbe et cinq
noms avec tomber un qui arrive haye adam
prend des cats échec pardon pas vu alors
peut-être il faut faire cavalier f3
échec d'abord on çà sent qu'il ya un
math roi fin damien raux gîte tour f5
attendait damien roy j'ai deux tours f5
ça paraît fort parce qu'il ya needham
des quatre needham b2 je vois pas de
problème après tour f5 ouais on menace
d'alger un match qu'on a protégé le
cavalier il n'y a pas de dire pas
d'échec possible et aller le score qui
continue à enfler 4 0 il est facile
ike il est très très facile dans ce
match quasiment des de npj j'ai pas vu
je n'ai pas regardé 1
ouais bientôt l'adoption alors après il
ya une règle qui nous avait été proposé
par le chat hier que j'avais bien aimé
mais que je souhaiterais ou avant-hier
que je souhaiterais améliorons nous
avait proposé car en cas de différence
de cinq points le match soit arrêté ça
c'est théorique fou g4 je crois ici
autour des 8 faisait 4 mais moi je
propose une autre règle alors une contre
règle ce qu'on appellerait la règle que
knockout c'est à dire qu'à n'importe
quel moment dans le match à n'importe
quel moment dans le match
si un joueur gagne 5 parties d'affilée
le match est gagné par k o c'est à dire
que ça rendrait les matchs intéressants
dans le sens où même si tu es mené à 8,1
tu pourrais espérer tout misé sur le
bullet et tenter un 5 0 à la fin tu
pourrais tenter une série d' engager
cinq à un moment donné quoi ce serait
pour regarder les matches un peu
intéressant jusqu'au bout parce que là
en réalité on est à 50 milles de match
on se rend pas compte mais ça fait
depuis depuis la 20e minute de jeu je
pense que qu'on compare moi ça fait déjà
la première dès la première minute de
jeu que je connais que je connaissais le
l'issue du match
mais là j'ai envie de dire l'issue du
match ne fait quasiment plus aucun doute
un cdu 99,5 contre 0,5 et à peu près une
chance sur 200 que km/heure retour le
match genre tu remontes 8,6 et tuer mais
tu gagne par ko locke chasse thévenet
8,1 mais en fait tu fais chaos
tu gagne par ko tu gagnes cinq parties
d'affilée ses carreaux est apte à gagner
le match
c'est un peu comme un uppercut à la boxe
quoi tu es mené aux points tu te fais
défoncer ce qu'en réalité en
à la boxe est un peu le même truc les
matches durs mais si tu te fais pas
complètement fouillé c'est parce que tu
sais qu'à un moment donné même si le mec
qui y mène aux points
théo 11e ronde au 10e round mais si le
mec à un moment donné lui met une patate
il le met ko il met par terre le match
d'hier tournée tu sais que le match qui
peut se retourner à la boxe même si
l'autre il a gagné les huit premiers
rangs d'un moment donné il s'en prend
une c'est fini bâle a en fait ce serait
pour garder un peu dangereux parce que
sinon ça sert à rien
c'est une règle qui ne sera pas adopté
d'ailleurs un les gars il faut le savoir
je viens de vous donner une règle qui ne
sera pas adopté la saison prochaine mais
ça aurait pu être une idée qui me qui me
paraît intéressante
jeanjean frais le retour mais ce ne sera
pas acceptée et si tu fais nul la série
s'arrête
par contre ça et à max parce que sinon
c'est trop chaud c'est un truc qui doit
être hyper rare mais qui doit te laisser
une chance à un moment donné tu en
gagnes de et ont commencé à vibrer
et puis ça permettrait dans des matches
comme ça parfois d'abréger les
souffrances
c'est à dire que là en fait je pense
cité km heure ta quasiment envie de la
perdre exprès d'arrêter mais ça peut
être marrant la règle du carreau tu as
vraiment une bonne intuition pour
l'événementiel ouais
ah ben oui je dois dire que oui
kane qui est pas convaincu bas ce serait
déjà mieux c'est pour améliorer leur
truc moi je ferai comme moi c'est à dire
la règle 17 je trouve que c'est beaucoup
mieux
mais quitte à faire un match en longueur
il faudrait qu'il y ait une règle pour
pouvoir tuer l'adversaire à un moment
donné que sinon on fait la tat de trois
heures de contenu qui arrivent et qui
qui sont sans suspens après moi comme je
vous dis je suis content parce que j'ai
fait mon petit tweet là il ya tout point
f7 qui fait mal sur dame prend il ya des
six sur trois points ya des six ça ça
tue le statut la partie donc quand même
cette dame premier set dé 6,6 et finir
et il a très bien joué mais qui il fait
une petite grimace
ça va faire cinq verres là il peut faire
un truc marrant c'est tout recettes sur
dame prend 1,7 ya des six c'est drôle
bah disons après j'ai une super g j'ai
l'intuition dans le monde des échecs on
va dire mais c'est vrai que je suis
d'accord avec toi c'est par rapport aux
c'est plutôt par rapport aux autres en
fait
en fait c'est quand même le plus gros
poisson d'un petit étang dans un océan
je serais peut-être pas aussi bon mais
dans un petit étang
je peux être assez bon c'est surtout ce
à quoi je suis d'accord avec toi là
dessus après le truc c'est que j'ai eu
la chance j'ai eu la chance d'avoir une
carrière de joueur de poker pendant
quelques années et ça permet de se
mettre plus facilement la place des
autres en fait on peut dire que ça
apporte cette qualité là de jouer au
poker c'est quand tu joue au poker en
fait à ça ça se permet de phase ii plus
facilement te projeter sur ce que
pensent les autres en fait et te
demander à ce que les ce que les autres
pensent de ce que tu fait ou de ce qui
est fait là il ya peut-être à des 6 3 h
8 ont plongé cette dame prend g7 ya pas
d 7 sera protégé pour même si on
pourrait prendre prendre prendre faire
fou à quatre on est gagnant trois genres
même ça c'est gagnant même là où se
seraient trompés
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être même très
fort on se retrouve quand même dans une
position avec trois pions de plus c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être la meilleure
variante en vrai
autre idée bataille équipe dans traîne
alors j'ai un soap bat avec genre team
femmes et petit medley les teams caf
timba qui met en fait de sape de quoi en
fait je comprends pas trop édité à votre
veille taux d'apprentis pas de jouer à
utiliser qui coûte très cher en fait
mais c'est plus marrant de faire des
battles contre d'autres streamer du coup
ça fait plus de grip
non mais c'était pas la meilleure
variante mettons pranger 7,17 il faillit
se trouve que là il n'y a pas de mauvais
coups tu as déjà trois pions de plus
donc virtuellement tu as déjà une pièce
de plus avec les blancs donc à peu près
tout va gagner en fait ça c'est fini
elle a 17 c'est quoi le problème
quelqu'un qui procède par dont jean paul
ii mais même ça c'est gagnant j'ai
oublié que ton change et 7 lits d'ester
d'enlever le truc mais je pense t-on
pranger 7,17 le truc j'ai montré c'est
vraiment une simplification cool
après je l'aurais pas jouer tu vois je
n'aurais pas pousser la variante là
c'est juste on vous parle en fait que je
les ai poussés par hasard
pourquoi il abandonne pas ah ben il va
faire sa ré pas le truc en fait preuve
et l'abandonnent pas parce que de toute
façon il doit se taper encore deux
heures et demie de match donc il
abandonne maintenant qu'ils abandonnent
dans la partie suivante change pas grand
chose en fait
il joue ça aille qui joue ce truc là
n'est de toute façon
j'ai presque envie de dire vu le nombre
de spectateurs est bon allez je vais
faire une blague on la fera plus tard la
blague on était un peu trop limites dans
l'ami qui commence déjà à s'amuser qui
change de répertoire non mais abandonner
la game ouais en fait avant de la game
est là pourquoi tu abandonnes pas déjà
en fait fin tu pourrais passer ta vie
abandonné fin tu tues tu sais que là à
la place de gamer lâcherait très énervé
de voir continuer à jouer c'est c'est là
c'est humiliant en fait ce qui se passe
elle passait pas la voir la bague il à
la blague ouais mais là c'est humiliant
fait de continuer à jouer fait tout le
monde voit que t'es nul c'est terrible
les gens qui avaient encore un doute sur
ton niveau ont compris que bon bah en
fait je prends très cher un con tu me
quittes à riom si jouer à 100% il met 10
0 sans problème à rick mais juste moi je
sais mais si je fais un match contre lui
tout le monde va savoir
ouais mais trois au sol et rappelé à 30
euros et c'est notre mai trois auraient
ils jouent pas charmé 3 aux tablettes
tournant à 30 euros gros
ouais j'aime semble regarder une vidéo
asm ouais moi aussi il suffire il
suffirait plus que micky m mais tin oo
en cuir et à émettre une cagoule sur la
tête de vincent km heure on est très
très malin
non mais c'est pas agréable de jouer un
match comme ça c'est très désagréable je
sais pas je sais pas si vous faites du
sport mais c'est quand même si on va
faire un tennis que tu sais que tu vas
prendre 6 r 6 r en fait est qu'il ya
5000 personnes qui regardent ou 4000
c'est pas agréable en fait t'as 4000
personnes qui viennent voir trente six
heures 6 heures parce que là c'est
l'équivalent de six aires 6è rens qui va
se prendre c'est c'est désagréable
fadil on t'a pris 5-0 là ok mais tu va
taper encore deux heures et demie
d'humiliation là le pire c'est que ça va
durer encore longtemps et ça va être
long et pénible
là je pense que l'expression prend tout
son sens là ça va vraiment être bien
long et bien pénible un ca en convient
aux échecs là c'est une formule avec du
temps malheureusement et c'est vraiment
psychologiquement dur pour vincent c'est
en vrai ça me fait du mal ce 6,6 à ce
format me fait du mal pour les joueurs
aussi
c'est très humiliant
ouais c'est même pas si c'est un bo là
il pourrait déjà nous comptons fédé b
ont fait des dbo5 du coup on fait des bo
5 ans est donc là il y aurait déjà un 7
0 2 0
en gros encore une victoire de dyk et ce
sur le match serait fini là il va se
taper encore deux heures et demie de
match honnêtement c'est dur
psychologiquement pour à 20 cents
martirosyan est beaucoup plus fort en
blitz way sur internet très fort c'est
pas s'il peut prendre dix il en prend 10
en fait c'est l'humiliation ultime aux
échecs ce qu'on appelle à l'adoption
et là tu te fait humilier au tennis tu
peux revenir dans le match où elle
atteint vite un point de non-retour en
fait 5 points je dirais ça fait déjà
très mal s'il est mené genre après on va
dire deux heures de jeu 8 1 c'est déjà
vraiment fini en fait de 7 points on va
dire ce sera vraiment fini à 100% et tu
as encore 1h 1h30 de jeu à tirer bat
haute et se fait défoncer ça dure pas
non mais tu vas passer trois heures et
demie à te faire bon vous avez le mot
que je veux dire j'ai pas besoin de lire
vous pouvez insérer vous même dans le
chat mais ça va durer trois heures
trente et trois heures trente c'est long
c'est très très long c'est très très
très long c'est vraiment très difficile
à vivre en hongrie va de nouveau se
faire des fonds sallèles d'amin sait
maintenant il te dira te faire masser et
pas que ray
non non c'est difficile
fois ci donc il veut viser la case d3
massage foot option cap à fond mais
vraiment toutes options la clac a même
pris trop d'options en fait dans ton
message
honnêtement je trouve pas ça une yanka
refus conscient qu'à 15 ans le gars à
trois mille fois mon niveau et peut-être
trois fois plus intelligent
oui mais c'est juste que t'as pas envie
que ça dure trois heures trente
à force de te faire battre bad bad bad
bad ça devient chiant en fait c'est
juste que t'as pas envie en fait c'est
chez passe comme si tu as envie de des
potes à la maison à jouer à fifa que le
gates ami déjà 4 x 6 0 dans les matches
et que tu vas pas en jouer quatre de
match que tu va en jouer 25 phare moment
donné ok il est plus fort bravo tu as
gagné et tu lui serre la main et tu pars
ça ça va mais si on fait si tu es obligé
de rejouer rejouer rejouer rejouer il ya
un moment donné ou juste mentalement
c'est dur
exactement cello 23 qui a fait une bonne
analogie séquence était ko à la boxe au
deuxième rang mais qu'on continue à
taper dessus et ouais c'est exactement
ça l'enquêté carotter carreaux bravo le
mcee plus fort ça c'est pas humiliant
par contre quand le mec commence à taper
au sol c'est chiant t'as pas par terre
et là le truc c'est que là on tape par
terre en fait c'est que là il ya pas un
arbitre qui vient et qui dit ok les gars
il ya cinq verres en arêtes lalanne en
place et il ya cinq jours on va
continuer encore deux heures la tiens tu
vas prendre très cher c'est difficile
même pour le joueur qui gagne c'est
chiant alors pour le joueur qui gagne un
truc psychologique qui peut être
compliqué à gérer et c'est un peu le
problème qu'avait une épaule notamment
compté g contre danielian c'est qu'à un
moment donné tu sens que tu me lis
vraiment le mec et à peut-être plus
envie de le battre en fait d'ailleurs la
haye convoi qui s'est trompé mais à un
moment donné peut-être inconsciemment tu
vas lui les ont laissés gagner une ou
deux parce que juste c'est c'est too
much en fait ouais tu peux avoir un peu
pitié de l'adversaire oui et c'est
normal et c'est plutôt humain et c'est
plutôt bien d'ailleurs car la scène dans
les spas une oie et mais c'est un
caractère spécial de pas en laisser une
c'est un caractère de champion
c'est bien c'est très bien aussi d'avoir
un caractère de champion comme ça de
vouloir tout le temps écraser tout le
monde sait bien mais après à la il ya un
truc dit laure dit c'est qu'il prend 1,4
puis on prend et dames f6 pas facile à
voir comme tactique mais un gars du
calibre de martirossian peut l'avoir en
glisse en longue c'est facile hein par
contre
ouais ce match et +12 celui de l'epo
dans le sens où nippo danielian en fait
elle sait d'avancé qu'elle va qu'elle va
perdre à 0 où elle va marquer un ou deux
points là en fait km heure
psychologiquement ce peut être plus
pénible puisque genre ça un espoir ou
quoi en fait et là on voit que bon se
peut qu'à mettre un espoir mais disons
que ça peut être plus pénible il a raté
le cas il prend 1,4 mais là encore je
pense que si le match est serré qui
avait les preuves 4 il le voit il est
vraiment tranquille là ne dépense pas
être considéré comme un manque de
respect bah je sais pas un moment donné
quand tu mènes vraiment beaucoup pour
que ça me soit arrivée en fait dans la
position du perdant et du gagnant fête
est un moment donné tu peux un peu un
peu lâché
georges me rappelle quand j'avais fait
le stream que j'avais un peu joué contre
alexandra botez en fait je n'avais pas
du tout envie de gagner sur un gros
score
donc c'était serré j'aurais y avait 1-1
2-2 et puis après j'ai comme envie de
gagner donc j'ai dû gagner 4 2 ou 6 2
mai mais en fait t'as pas forcément tu
vois je n'avais aucune envie de mettre
10 0 alexandra en fait parce que je me
sens juste mal j'ai pu j'ai pas envie en
fait c'est pas elle est sympa et
toujours pas pourquoi je mettrais 10-0
gagner oui parce que j'ai envie mais à
la différence de niveau est clair avant
le match n'était pas moi qui vais mettre
10 euros mvl tu vois oui parce que
normalement il peut remonter à tout
moment donc je suis obligé d'être en
contrôle mais quand le match est déjà
bien t'as pas envie quoi après ça c'est
tout un chacun sa ccta des gens qui s'en
foutent à des gens qui s'en foutent pas
ouais j'avais refusé moi moi j'aime pas
mais là y'a un petit piège vous prend à
6 pages et prendre ce qu'il ya des
problèmes 6 mai damage trois dames 1
dames ici
alors est ce qui la fout pas fou prend
il veut tourcoing f3 maintenant et le
truc en plus qui est inquiétant pour
gamer c'est que je pense que un plus un
ce sera sa pire cadence donc si comptait
revenir en fin de match sur le bullet je
pense que ça va être encore pire
et là il ya dame b 6 dame prend des six
il est dans un fauteuil micky 6r allait
me qui allait plus que quatre mois il
gagne vraiment dans un fauteuil il gagne
sans forcer il force vraiment pas son
talent l'adjoint arménien il boxe juste
4 4 catégories au dessus de son
adversaire c'est tout un sympa ce petit
match un petit petit massacre entre amis
je suis très heureux
je suis très dangereux car un peu
twitter est ce que ça raconte j'ai que
trois like c'est terrible et j'en sais
les gens sont vraies suis vraiment pas
cette compét
même quand notre joueur rentre tout le
monde s'en fiche c'est incroyable
y a que trois like sûr sûr sûr twitter
quoi c'est trois gemmes c'est terrible
ça intéresse personne tout le monde s'en
fout quoi notre notre joueur favori
rentrer tout le monde s'en fout oui
c'est dur pour cammas a fait aussi
preuve si je vous assure que
psychologiquement un moment donné
vraiment je sais pas si j'ai déjà vécu
des trucs comme ça
cc c'est vraiment dur je me répète mais
c'est vraiment chiant et
psychologiquement à vivre est-ce que je
suis le seul de chasse comme à être un
lieu aussi critique ce genre de tournoi
alors oui et non
oui et non en fait on en a plein qui
commande juste pas l'événement mais qui
disent que c'est très bien on va dire
que je suis le seul à argumenter ma
pensée alliés mais acta mais mes paroles
supporter partir aussi parce qu on est
très heureux disons qu'on va dire que
les matchs qui ont le scénario qu'on est
en train de vivre sont trop présents
pour que le format tienne la route
en fait s'il avait que des matchs serrés
en fait le format de 3h30 c'est très
bien aussi
le ratio de matches serrés c'était on va
dire 50 50 mais je pense que le ratio ta
genre 25% de match serré entre 20 et 25%
de match serré et tu dois avoir 50%
match oui qui vont complètement à sens
unique et 25% tu peux penser à un moment
donné que ça va se tourner mais s'est
jamais vraiment serré du coup il s'en
sort de nouveaux pas mal martirossian ça
doit être plus ou moins égale ça par
contre
maroc et en retour est bien
la cage de but arménien je crois qu'il a
21 martirossian mais il avait gagné la
rai auro flatter tous et c'est un joueur
connu après il est il est trop âgé pour
avoir un avenir quelconque dans le top
mondial mais ce sera un bon joueur à
2007 je pense est un bon blitzer une
nulle et vite l'adoption malheureusement
et je pense pas qu'ils aient d'adoption
parce que j'ai l'impression que
martirossian à vraiment baisser le
baisser le rythme
voyez plus assez jeune je voulais dire
martirossian pour avoir un avenir dans
le top niveau d'un calage c'est sûr
toujours avons pu percer à 16 17 ans tu
sait généralement déjà s'ils peuvent
être top mondial déjà à 13 ans j'ai un
13 14 ans a déjà éliminé beaucoup mais
c'est 17 ans ait à une vraie idée
donc
ça continue
ce qu'un jeune si j'ai mis dans une
pièce sans souvent bah en fait j'aimais
bien le petit abou sow toorop mes murs
tasma convaincu de penser qu'ils
seraient jamais champion du monde donc
on va faire classique firouz jamais je
suis loin d'être sûr alors fou prend g7
ça marche pas à cause du roi prend g7 et
surtout reprend ses six vous prend ses 6
ça permet une tour
il est pas nue la douce autographes mais
il a un style où il crée rien en fait ce
que m'a expliqué mur face lui qui le
connaît mieux parce qu'il vit en
ouzbékistan et du coup il m'a dit en
fait c'est un joueur qui fait rien il a
il joue solide mais il crée y crée pas
le jeu quoi et ça généralement c'est un
problème
ça généralement c'est un problème pour
arriver au top top après on verra
ce que martyr juif c'est un type de
voiture par tuer non comme tu vois il
joue assez classique martirossian mais
est très très fort tacticien par contre
là il va juste faire nul 1
juniors c'est moins de 21 ans ya tout
qui s'échange 1 impression vraiment que
martirossian est passé en mode gestion
il va gérer le match maintenant
il va prendre les nuls quant à elles
s'offrent à lui et il va arriver à juger
un façon il sait qu en bullet il est
beaucoup plus fort il l'a vu qu'il a
plus qu'à gérer
elles viennent là vraiment percé percée
sur le tard mais c'était un jeune déjà
très très talentueux il était champion
du monde sait plus quelle catégorie il
était très fort après la percée au top
top plus tard
je suis quand même étonné que les rues
de broadcast pas le match parce que
martirossian quand même singes aux
arméniens les arméniens je rappelle son
pour la beaucoup d'arméniens russophone
je suis étonné que les russes broadcast
pas du tout levelt font l'impasse adha
ça y est les portugais ont commencé avec
du retard en fait sont venus après une
heure de match gamer qui propose nul
c'est dommage que ça va être tué grâce à
a tué le petit intérêt qu'ils avaient de
l'adoption
s'il accepte ce serait chiant qu'il
accepte mais il va accepter c'est sûr il
est tourner le chrono sont là je pense
que les deux joueurs savent plus ou
moins que le match effet vous pourrez
rentrer dans un faux rythme maintenant
non pas d'adoption
c'est malheureux
c'est malheureux s'arrête je la montre
ouais mais après après ces jours-là
monde pour qu'ils aient moins deux
parties dans le match pour avoir à moins
jouer c'est ça en fait je pense que les
deux joueurs seraient contents d'en
rester là km/heure doit savoir que le
match est perdu martirossian n'a pas
forcément envie d' humilier l'adversaire
ça doit qu'il est cool mais est-ce qu'un
jour alors j'avais pris le parti d'en le
score mode pas mettre les nuls cyril
dans tous les cas pour qu'on ait le
nombre de victoires à la fin il n'y a
pas de temps après il ya une heure de
démons six morts il ya une heure de 3 +
5 ans même après attention pour être
bien sûr mais qu'a eu marre il va en
gagner une là c'est sûr
surplus qui soit 0 ap un peu plus qu'il
soit 0 faut qu'ils gagnent parlement il
a toujours pas gagné c'est quoi l'enjeu
de ce tournoi je crois que tu peux
gagner sept huit mille dollars en tout
quand additionne tous les prix que tu
gagnes à chaque tour non mais le tiercé
pour être bien sûr là on n'est pas bien
sûr encore
il ya eu qu'une nul pour le mans poule
le curry
ouais dur
du rhin
on peut croire une opposition encore
s'ils ont rejoint le live vous y voilà
c'est ça les gens qui rejoignent peuvent
encore y croire
il joue bien ce martirossian un vraiment
bon joueur
devenons alors foot deux heures et
quarante parties supplémentaires que des
fois qu'il m'a passé un cap là tout de
suite
qu'est ce qui se passe en bas de chez
moi
de nouveau le bordel devant chez moi
c'est fou
c'est génial que ça va peut-être partir
en baston c'est beau ouais c'est vrai
c'est souvent un peu souvent un peu
tendu c'est souvent un peu tendu
le soir quand les shorty chien il ya
quelqu'un qui essaie de plus ou moins
embrouillée quoi c'est c'est terrible
heureusement que heureusement que sarah
go commenté le fatah mais y'a rien il ya
rien eu un bon j'suis pas voilà partis
là se déroule son jeu des gros ballons
intimider nan mais bon après
après c'est pas mal parce c'est pas mal
passé
non michel non mais michel s'en fout
complètement michel voulait quand même
jouer quoi
il va récupérer le pion au 5 mai s'ils
ont des cats que ça est une force une
faiblesse on va le voir
joli des quatre reste est le coup le
plus logique aussi un après il va
récupérer 1,4 en afrique a eu cinq
peut-être qu'il va venir en des six
escales rallier peut être pénible
on va voir
il reste combien de temps dans cette
cadence plus de dix minutes il reste
deux parties encore
je pense qu'il doit partir pour
cavaliers 4k et des six
je pense qu'il doit partir pour quatre
des six qui avaient lieu deux de visu
j'arrête pas trop j'aurais peur de me
prendre des détroits qui est prend 1,5
on y réfléchit en tout cas invoquer
prendre c'est si c'était c'est vrai
aussi une option
il faut autre chose qu'à prendre c'est
cissé prend 2,5
quand les six ans passant est motivé à
gagner ouais tu as l'impression que tu
vas te faire arnaquer tout le temps est
mieux cacher mon premier cours de
l'année à une des classes aujourd'hui en
arborant fièrement un t-shirt bitstream
ça fait de la pub gratos gouttes merci à
toi ben ichou
george's stream qui est fièrement arboré
en espérant que ça motive les petits à
venir s'abonner bail à faire ça c'est
quoi être 8 il menacera attention dame
prend 1,4 dame points 4 fou prend h 2
salut nathan le requin c'est dur de
tenir des cats en moi je trouve qu'il
est blindé des quatre ce qui aurait dû
recettes de le pousser mais de le tenir
il va jouer la colonne où il va jouer la
taxe sur le roi et le pion des cas tu
seras jamais assez attaqué il va jouer
aussi la tac avec à 4 ira anti micky
ward à like ait qui a ralenti mais non
ça c'est ça je suis d'accord avec vous
dans mais c'est clair la queue il joue
pas avec le frein à main mais il joue
beaucoup plus tranquille qu au début un
il en mode gestion
après il serait vraiment temps qu'il s'y
montrent à +8 +10 une fois que tu as
plus disent tu es vraiment tranquille tu
a quasiment gagné mathématiquement donc
il peut refaire encore un petit un petit
effort
j'ai 3 il va prendre en b3 s va
peut-être mettre une tour en b 8 ans à 3
alors il va faire coiffer retour à deux
fous g7
d'accord il anticipe les problèmes
j'imagine qu'il va venir fixer le pion
et l'attaqué allez y le fixe une
première fois vous avez peut-être une
tour en huit préparer f5 et tout reprend
b4
j'avais pas vu à cassis frei mais c'est
parce qu'en fait tu combinent en fait
avec la dame regarde tu contrôles tout
l'échiquier donc tu peux combiner les
attaques allèles damas allait droit à
l'eva il va rester une partie dans la
cadence après il y aura encore une heure
et demie de match à venir
en vrai on aurait pu avoir des scénarios
similaires les autres jours un tellement
c'était sûr que le favori gagnerait tu
penses à différence d'âge une important
dans ce match va bien sûr km/heure dans
quelques années il pourra voir le niveau
de martirossian juste aujourd'hui c'est
même étrange de les faire jouer l'un
contre l'autre pour dire vrai il va
prendre b4
alors attention à tête du contre jeu-là
martirossian il a peut-être été trop
facile
il s'est mis en danger
bref dommage qu'on puisse pas pareil et
moi aussi j'aurais envoyé très cher sur
sur martirossian le match là surtout
qu'on nous vend d'un match mumbai oui ce
match là il va être serré moi j'ai tout
de suite dit oui il va être serré de
rien du tout et j'ai tout de suite dit
que ça allait pas du tout être serré
c'était évident que ce serait pas
céréales et dames c'est un jamais être
là tous ont bien il va les mater à
l'ancienne
celui-ci l'après move carrillo cette
juste 3f cette crise prises 3g 3g set il
s'est trompé
oh là là incroyable c'est lui qui se
fait mater il suffisait de jouer trois
sets alors on va peut-être marcher pas
ici roi g8 qui gagnait tout de suite
courage et cette dame des 4 c'est fini
moi j'ai huit dames des huit dames 7
matt hahn hon dames 7 saddam a fuité
damache huit matches terribles
martirossian qui se déconcentre et ça
fait 6 1 il a été trop facile hein et il
a fait une grosse gaffe farwell plaide
c'est juste que le match est tellement
déséquilibrée et que le score est
tellement fait qu'il a fait un gros
cadeau la haye qu il a fait un énorme
cadeau
ah ouais mais ce que je vous disais 1
c'est le risque quand c'est vraiment
trop facile c'est de faire un gros
cadeau après ça remet pas en cause sa
domination mais bon
ça revient à cinq points
des concentrations et des concentrations
sarah sandra tel gars faciaux à metz que
ce que j'explique souvent 1,6 d'eads
mise à c'est qu'en réalité quand on est
déconcentré fatigué manque de motivation
notre niveau il baisse vraiment
énormément là il n'a pas vu un match en
quatre mois ce qui doit avoir
normalement il a joué tempo juste il
était plus concentré quoi
il a juste été il s'est juste
déconcentrer c'est là aussi qu'on voit
la différence de caractère les joueurs
du top niveau en fait ils continuent
tout le temps
on va voir sa relance un peu le match
après ça remet pas en cause le scénario
voix martirossian qui a agacé quand même
de deux sont ratés
du moins ça me fait du bien oui mais
faut pas que tu crois mais nous quand on
est déconcentré on joue aussi très mal
dès qu'on arrête de calculer notre
niveau ils baissent drastiquement
dès qu'on est plus concentré qu'on
arrête de calcul et qu'on arrête de
faire les efforts on chute complètement
il al'air dépressive est intéressant il
va pleurer pas honnêtement je comprends
le match est très long tu vas y mène de
beaucoup il doit se projeter lui aussi
sur quelque chose qui va durer encore au
moins deux heures avec les pauses et
c'est pas c'est pas un plaisir en fait
donc là il s'est déconcentré peut-être
par ennui et il doit il doit se
remobiliser mais c'est pas un plaisir de
jouer ça mais d'où l'intérêt de marek du
chaos en fait par l'âme km/heure aurait
déjà perdu le match mais à l'intérêt de
la règle du chaos c'est que ok tu en as
gagné une part à des concentrations gpat
en gagner une deuxième et tout d'un coup
2 3 0 tu mets la pression quoi
en tout cas c'est la dernière partie de
de la séquence
après wells a vu là c'est différent ils
jouent beaucoup plus positionnelle mais
à martirossian c'est aussi un joueur qui
calculait qui est plus en force à moi
aussi d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai des
problèmes dès que j'arrête de calculer
je suis quand même un peu en force
c'est un autre style mais c'est pas
facile de tout le temps faire les
efforts
mazet ceni alpha 0-100 microprocesseurs
caezar et quels sont les têtes d'affiché
bon je dirais par ami al sarine attaqué
six pieds n'co et abdou s'auto rohff
là il y aura il y aura des y aura des
beaux matchs ira du level abdou sow
toorop contraint ait martirossian même
s'ils sont pas dans la même partie de
tableau ça peut ça peut faire des
étincelles abdou sauteur a fait beaucoup
plus fort que kaymer en blitz c'est pas
la même limonade
dans ce premier tour il ya très peu de
matchs intéressants praga nom d'anne ans
il va se faire déchirer il n'a pas le
niveau
cet homme n'a pas le niveau
je n'y crois pas une seule seconde de
sauter font croire à un sprinter
abdoujaparov way qui sévissent et sur le
tour de france hier le match était
intéressant à tous et contre toute
attente un contre toute attente le match
d'hier a été serré et on va dire qu'on
était comme j'ai dis à chaque fois c'est
du 90 10 là j'aurais mis 95,5 moi
personnellement même si on m'a dit que
ça serait serré et après tu en as un de
temps en temps qui sera serré rester
celui d'hier
ouais ouais kemmer celui qui avait fait
une énorme perf dans un trou en
allemagne mais voilà qui confirme sans
fin qui confirme et qui confirme pas non
plus fait ces tournois open ya neuf
rondes souvent les trois quatre
premières rondes sont plus faciles après
il suffit que tu as un peu de réussite
sur deux trois parties et tu peux le
gagner même si la cote et hot quoi mais
ça veut pas forcément dire que tu fais
partie du top mondial
bon difficile d'avancer là pour les deux
joueurs au centre
mais damas je crois peut-être mais le
pion est pas très difficile à défendre
après c'est une option 1 mais genre ça
va pas changer la face du monde
il va se lancer dans des échanges bien
que l'autre va reprendre du fou pour
mettre la pression sur eux
ben moi qui aie mari m'a jamais trop
impressionné enfin il est beaucoup plus
fort que moi mais je ne trouve pas
impressionnant après
ouais mais même en classement elo il est
combien dans sa catégorie km heure on va
regarder
il doit avoir un gros classement dans sa
catégorie d'âge mais disons tu vas fuir
ou de jacky à deux ans de plus
il est quand même 2007 plus quoi déjà la
halle à 25,68 il met plus les catégories
d'âge il a 16 ans 25 68
tu vois firoud déjà on april a pas joué
depuis quelques mois il est 24e junior
quoi
je sais pas assez fort mais c'est pas
non plus tu affirmes où déjà il a quoi
il a quel écart d'âge avec lui l'huile
est né en 2004 firouz j'apporte pour
donner un exemple d'un gars très fort et
connu presque valeur qui roulent déjà
mais cheyrou déjà il est il a un nom un
an de plus seulement il à 150 points et
l'autre plus et les 150 points à prendre
entre 25 70 c 27 20 je préfère vous dire
que c'est pas simple à
je sais pas ça me jérôme cas évidemment
il sera très très fort mais je veux dire
par là que pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
non plus il peut il peut très bien c'est
un genre de joueur qui peut stagner à 26
70 26 80 il est beaucoup plus fort que
moi il est même beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus fort que moi mais
on s'en fout d'être plus fort que moi en
fait il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
beaucoup plus forts que moi aux échecs
qui sont pas pour autant champion du
monde
bref irujo à 17 ans est donc oui disons
que très fort joueur bien sûr ce sera un
des meilleurs allemands évidemment il
rentrera dans le top 100 c'est
extrêmement probable après après de là à
faire partie du top 10 mondial est
menacé d'être champion du monde il ya
quand même encore un monde donc il a
beaucoup de qualités mais il va falloir
encore confirmé
quand tu as niveau et chez les juniors
arrêtent leurs études pour seuil et son
puissant aux échecs ça dépend les câlins
certains oui certains noms certains le
font et le regrettent par la suite aussi
mons on est mort alors attendez pas non
non mon sont à l'air bon alors il a
réussi à prendre le pion à et on va voir
comment ça va se finir désole un peu
petit peu pour pour le manque
d'enthousiasmé sur les partis et être
plus dans la discussion pour ceux qui
veulent vraiment suivre le match
après malheureusement le score semble
fait martirossian qui hésite de nouveau
à prendre là nul façon il a le match en
poche
il fait nul et voilà ça ça a tourné à
6-1 face est ainsi on compte les nuls
dans cette cadence
ah bon on va faire une pause on va faire
une petite pause non voit que ouais
martirossian est en plein en plein
contrôle
il a il a le match en poche je vais vous
repassez comme l'air quand on a fait les
dernières fois cette partie en entier et
on va se faire une petite pause je mette
un chronomètre de cinq minutes pour qui
un chrono pour le retour
je mette la petite pub on va y aller
mince le chrono n'aurait pas eu de
commencer
je vais commencer trop tôt on finira on
arrêtera peut-être le stream un tout
petit peu avant la fin je mette la
petite et des moustiques qui m'attaquent
la petite pub et on se retrouve dans
cinq petites minutes
les mecs
ça rejoint où il se passe quoi je vois
dans le chat non ça joue pas est-ce que
je filme sur ma chaîne en or à longwy
avec mathieu cornette
normalement oui zig on verra si c'est
plus intéressant que ce match on espère
tu sévère qu'à leurs finances prévu
21h37 art mais peut-être si le match est
vraiment finie on commencera un peu
avant 7 on commencera à 21h
à tout moment après de façon à la le
match d'aujourd'hui
mais bon j'ai l'impression de vous dire
ça tous les jours mais là c'est bien y'a
même pas une once de suspense quoi c'est
dommage
franchement c'est dommage c'est dommage
parce qu'il va y avoir des baux quarts
de finale et des belles femmes des demi
finales sur des quarts de finale et on a
certaines qui seront bel et c'est
dommage de faire ça en introduction de
l'événement parce que du coup ça ça tue
un peu les veines je trouve de faire
huit matches comme ça où il aurait fallu
jouer quatre en même temps et quatre en
même temps je trouve que c'est dommage
de d'otan montrer ces choses là aussi
longtemps
après c'est mon avis mais je pense que
rien utt mieux et comment c'est évident
à et éventuellement les matchs de
manière individuelle à partir des quarts
ou des demies peut-être de faire rejouer
4 4 8e et 4 8e en même temps quoi sur
deux jours et commencer et commencer les
choses sérieuses séparés en grand format
à partir des à partir des quarts ça
aurait été plus heureuse que je veux le
title tuesday à metz et tous les mardis
bardamu aller title tuesday depuis
quatre ans donc si tu suis la chaîne tu
dois à savoir normalement
normalement
alors ça reprend pas pour le moment on a
je suis en attente aux siens j'ai plus
de 2002 à cas là je sais plus trop à
[Musique]
mettre yogourt
mais j'ai eu 21 50 21 70 à ces jeunes
après j'ai un peu plafonné j'ai eu des
problèmes de santé aussi et c'est ça pas
été forcément facile
ah non mais l'êta est accusée bardamu ce
pas impossible de rater en fait c'est
tous les mardis depuis tellement
d'années je sais pas comment c'est même
la table en fait c'est même
difficilement rentable
mais j'ai pas comment tu as raté sa
bardamu
déjà tellement longtemps mais quatre ans
plus c'est est au bas mot savez
peut-être plus tôt cinq ans c'est
incroyable c'est un bon c'est reparti on
va voir si ça si ça revient un peu côté
côté allemand battue 3 + 1 maintenant eh
oui je sais idées avec le retardement du
coût des quatre et le h4 allez on va on
va c'est tout le mal qu'on lui souhaite
de revenir un peu dans cette partie dans
ce match plus tôt il reste combien de
temps demande manu adhère j'ai oublié de
remettre le chrono du coup on va le
mettre sur 58 il reste encore une heure
quarante-cinq de match après je te cache
pas c'est pas sûr que nous on suive
absolument jusqu'au bout manu parce
qu'il est prévu quelque chose avec
mathieu cornette et que le match est
plié depuis à peu près une heure déjà ou
quasi plié
donc c'est pas dit qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout du bout du bout mais reste encore
pas mal de temps tant mieux un fait
quand même d'aider belle à des belles
parties
pour info location et à réaliser les
clients ont fait l'essai ces grands prix
c'est un haka de parham artemiev
martirossian et donc j'y vais un firoud
kovalev à bezouce autographes et je me
suis pas trompé quand je vous ai dit les
jeunes qui étaient forts je vous ai cité
par as martirossian et firoud déjà et
abdou sow toorop jouer cité les quatre
comme quoi hein comme quoi je ne me suis
pas trompé
google dont google google goog hc de ces
au bonheur il s'est fait il s'est fait
écraser un nom dans google google ne
représente pas un danger pour pour des
joueurs de ce calibre
bien loin de là c'est pas assez forts du
cash camériste victoire et c'était prévu
à moi j'ai fait mon tweet 1 c'était bien
sûr prévu je faisais de me répéter parce
qu'on leur pose les mêmes questions mais
moi si mettez une cote à 1 20 à 25 je
m'étais all in 1 c'est pour moi et vous
allez un bon 95% de chances que
martirossian l'emportent après les
autres matches quand on aura abdou
s'auto rohff contre martirossian quoi là
ce sera intéressant
là il y aura quelque chose à regarder
donc j'ai quatre sur fg eelv quoi il
veut sûrement pas tout reprendre car il
faut prendre 5 qui doit vouloir
cavaliers prend fo prend b2 roi prend b2
il veut essayer de mener une attaque sur
le roi ça peut fonctionner ça peut
fonctionner on va voir
prise b2 prise b2 il va falloir faire
gaffe de passeront d'un math angers7 ici
il fait tout rêve c'est du coup il
plaint de son pion et ya pas de carélie
hafsi sur apprise en f 6 bêtement mais
qu'ayant eu 5
je pensais qu'ils mettraient la tour ans
et 7 mai tour f6 ma foi pourquoi pas ça
reste dans le domaine du jouable en tête
à cinq tours à cet ours et huit tours
c'est cette way les deux options sont
viables je m la tour ans et 7 c'était
l'idée qu'a rédigé quatre
il attaque est la tour qui va
probablement repartir en f7 afin de
blinder le pion
ça a l'air ça a l'air d'aller pour le
joueur arméniens qui a valu au sein qui
va être la tour en hausse est ça arrive
à échanger mettra la tour e set et le
pion h5 va être en l'air il va tenter la
tension qui avait profité ce qui menace
il va devoir le roi h7 est maintenant il
va tenter tour f 5 fu prend h5 la
position
semble être maintenant très correct pour
les noirs parce que s'il prend h5 qui
l'échangé qui va prendre aussi ça fera
deux pions de plus alors qu'at-il va
essayer de s'ouvrir la colonne pour
sauver au 6 mai ça va être quand même
compliqué car il y trois tours prend h5
j'imagine
on va prendre le pion au passage en
vient à eux cinq après il ya des
moustiques qui m'agresse complètement
c'est terrible il va prendre h5 il va
prendre six et maintenant il va
reprendre h5
ça fait trois pions par ok il ya deux
trois menaces avec lecavalier mais c'est
pas assez bien évidemment ça va suffire
pour le joueur arméniens qui reprend sa
marche en avant et qui reprend 6 points
d'avance donc il n'a pas encore
mathématiquement gagner le match et un
bien loin de là mais il construit y
construit sa victoire petit à petit
point après point partie après partie
minute après minute seconde après
seconde me renforce son avantage
espérant pour lui jusque jusqu'à la
victoire finale
ouais km heure par le haut niveau qu'est
ce qu'y at il à dire de plus une
nouvelle fois ci je me répète en fait
c'est un peu comme commenté une étape de
plat où il se passe rien pendant 180 km
mais sans les images d'hélicoptères et
les belles images quoi ça ressemble un
peu à ça de commenter ce genre de match
c'est un peu comme un tour de france
avec full plat peloton qui roule groupe
ait échappé avec un homme seul devant tu
sais qui va se faire reprendre et et pas
de reportages rien à montrer au public
c'est un peu spécial parce que les
partis au bout d'un moment
[Musique]
non avec une échappée avec un homme seul
je pense devant un jacky durand mais tu
sais qui se fait reprendre en fait tu en
fais tu n'as pas ta pas donc désolé je
suis pas forcément motivé pour vous
élisez partir à fond et tout mais juste
fait c'est tellement inéluctable en fait
c'est c'est hyper inéluctable
c'est 6 6 points d'avancé c'est énorme
maintenant il joue que des petites
finales technique et enfin disons que là
ils jouent vraiment en contrôle quoi
ouais jolie joue vraiment martyrs sans
jouer à bon escient banlieue de yerevan
ouhlala un grand trotteur qui va
d'origine arménienne pour connaître ça
parce que là c'est c'est de l'humour
c'est d'humour plus plus là faut avoir
les reins f1
justin montaigne un profond ennui bah en
fait ouais t'as ta roue gleacher roglit
chez eux et pour gadjard qui sont trop
forts et du coup la course allait
vraiment verrouiller la jeune on dit si
tu pouvais faire un pion prend ses six
intermédiaire fuhe deux pions prend 17
je pense et ce qu'ils calculent mais le
problème c'est que tu restes avec cette
fourchette enfin deux variantes
ça te donne envie en fait mais ça a pas
l'air de fonctionner mais c'est ce qui
calcule un bel objet de faire on apprend
et femmes et c'est ce qu'ils voulaient
essayer lui planter près on sent qu'il
est un peu dès que ça n'ait pas marché a
quand même on sent qu'il est bien dès
que ça n'ait pas fonctionné
qu'est qui va venir en d3 non nés en
vélo les gars y'a plus de y'a plus de
coureurs comme pantani comme machin qui
illuminait les courses et plus possible
et en plus tu as la jumbo qui a pris la
place d'ineos et qui verrouille la
course
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils font c'est même
plus verrouillée en fait c'est que tu
peux rien faire après ils ont les
meilleurs coureurs donc mais quand tu
vois que leurs sprinteurs entre guinée
sprinteurs vous devant arte
il emmène il emmène le peloton jusqu'à
quatre kilomètres jusqu'à quatre
kilomètres de l'arrivée en montagne qui
con tu veux attaquer ils ont encore du
moulin derrière pour pour emmener et ils
ont encore sept caisses à temps il a
carrément cette caisse qui lui a fait
l'esprit de la dernière fois c'était
l'étape d'hier il a dit là il a encore
un coureur qui lui ce qui lui ramène le
sprint en montagne à la fin du colombier
du grand colombier
ouais cette caisse qui me passe le
relais à 150 m qu'est ce que tu veux
faire en fait tu peux rien faire tu peux
pas les attaquer c'est impossible
le problème c'est pas forcément les
leaders le problème c'est les équipiers
non mais urano angel lopez six attaques
qui se font défoncer c'est pas possible
voilà la 4g 5 il est très très bien de
nouveau tu peux pas attaquer tu peux pas
attaquer et à toute attaque ou en fait
c'est du suicide d'attaqués
il peut peut-être faire qui est des six
la clé marrant je peux pas apprendre via
cavalia f5
tu peux tu peux pas tu peux pas attaquer
la jumbo visma c'est impossible
le seul qui peut attaquer cpo gatx are
well as ya toujours la tourte yves
arrivants h1 ouais ça fait très mal
c'est horrible les cavaliers sont trop
forts ici kaïs et huit cavaliers e set
et toura suite maths et oui jolis seins
le schéma de maths jolie le tableau de
maths et ça fait 8 1 7 points d'écart ça
gonfle les cars qui gonfle les amis en
faveur du joueur arménien c'est
difficile un poids pour gamer on va pas
lui jeter la pierre qui rejoue un genre
de rock opposé mais où ils ont peu plus
un
pourquoi je compte pas les nuls parce
que j'aime bien j'ai bien compté les
victoires en fait vraiment
j'aime bien compter que les victoires
presse a un goût personnel un tel savoir
combien de partis ont été gagnés en fait
ouais non les tours gagnés par indurain
c'était pareil hein faut pas se faire
d'illusions 1ere vidéo nazis ayant en
tête desquels des quatre intermédiaires
ici qui peuvent être cool pour p la
connexion de la tour
naf et dames c8 qui est intéressant
aussi un pour la peine
mais une dure n aujourd'hui si vous avez
le tour il ferait il serait par rapport
à la vitesse des coureurs aujourd'hui il
serait très très loin des leaders même
armstrong en fait il serait défoncé
aujourd'hui quand je regarde la vitesse
à laquelle ils montrent en fait même
lance amstrong
il serait pas dans le gruppetto mais il
serait pas dans le groupe des leaders
rivaux retour c8 qui va arriver et le
roi il va faire la gueule
il va y avoir beaucoup de trafic côté
blanc et la dame qui va être dans
beaucoup de problèmes non c'est
difficile de comparer entre générations
c'est comme aux échecs 1 tu ferais
revenir morphy même moi je le défonce
mais après tu le laisse entraîner
quelques mois avec le matériel qu'on a
aujourd'hui il a un tel talent qu'il me
il me des coupes en petites rondelles 1
armero glitch il est vraiment fort ça
fait un moment que c'est un bon courage
après il ya bien un jour la jumbo visma
ils vont pas être en forme c'est pas
possible
le mort fille de l'époque ouais je pense
que globalement fils d'époque il ya trop
de choses qui savent pas dans la théorie
dans les théories dans l'est dans les
trucs mais mais tu lui laisses quelques
mois et c'est fini j'ai aucune chance et
se passe quoi surtout c'est toi jouer
tempo c'était la question que je me
posais carrillo 7 qui tue la game 1 s'il
va encore gagner la qualité la km/heure
y est vraiment plus ça c'est des tac tic
tac tic week-end à lacets tactique
oricon la voilà c'est fini
cette tactique oricon de chez tactique
oricon blige et plus l'aïe a démissionné
à km heure là autour lincou marrant ces
dames des quatre pour jouer sur les
clous âge et vouloir dame prend des cinq
dames eu quatre ou six est marrant
l'heure où dame c4 mesdames quatre dames
c'est katia peut-être des f4 donc dam
des quatre en fait c'est mieux c'est un
clouage flux puissant mois il a pris des
seins et tous rêvent dé 8 mai il va se
voir se gagner cette finale
hu à l'époque ça défend des malouines
avec raven à l'époque les joueurs
défendent et très mal c'était une autre
époque
ils seraient choqués de cyrus y revenez
haïssent téléporté dans notre temps dans
notre temps par dont ils seraient
choqués de notes de nos défenses on
défend tellement mieux aujourd'hui
martirossian que c'est pas forcément
facilité la vie après contre un
adversaire plus fort il aurait peut-être
essayé de serrer la vis
là ils jouent en chaussons à maintenant
n'est pas allé quand même chercher un +
8 1 j'avais dit que plus de suite
c'était le moment tu pouvais vraiment
être détendu parce que même si tempère 2
tu restes à +6 et même si après quand tu
te remets en forme par une malchance
incroyable tant reperd 2 tu reste encore
à +4 donc encore une fois que tu as plus
8 tu peux vraiment trop lâcher
complètement
il peut plus rien arriver en fait est là
c'est bien il fait tout rejet trois
émanant y affèrent tours 7
il va forcer les changes et il va gagner
la finale tranquille ou pas d'ailleurs
peut-être faire f5 pour jouer quatre
tours prend des trois tours prend des
cinq tours pour h5 quoi encore plus
simple et c'est un abandon de gamer et
le score passe à neuf victoires à une
comme quoi s'il n'avait pas gaffer
jusque là seul parti qu'il a perdu c'est
une gaffe énorme dans une position où il
était à moins 25 sur l'ordi donc s'il
n'avait pas fait cette gaffe énorme
il aurait eu 10 victoires à zéro c'est
pour dire l'écart 1 le match dure encore
une heure et demie 6 truites chan
comment ça se disent étudier palais
défense à l'époque il savait pas sûr de
magnus
en fait tu savais pas à quel point ce
qui certaines positions été gagnante of
gamer c'est comme fortnight tu m'as un
joueur lambda dans le passé à la sortie
du jeu c'est un king exactement mais
vraiment en fait c'est la même chose
mais après tu m'as un top player tutu
fait venir un top player de l'époque il
fait étudier le jeu tu le fais jouer
deux semaines il va battre n'importe
quel joueur lambda lycée inhumain décès
le match se joue et c'est quasiment tous
les matches du premier tour qui sont
comme ça alors celui-là est vraiment
sévère au niveau du score mais les
autres auraient vraiment pu avoir le
même le même destin
les autres matches j'aurais pu avoir le
même destin vraiment en fait j'avais
plus de chance d'avoir ce destin là dans
un des autres matchs que d'avoir une
surprise mais vraiment en fait vous
rendez pas compte
salut qu elle fit sévit et je connais
ton amie rita sans vrai assez
extraordinaire mais je crois qu'il a eu
un problème de santé la résistance j'ai
cru dire qu'il avait dû se faire amputer
une jambe ou quoi c'est terrible c'est
une question d'appariement nan c'est une
question de format
ouais j'ai vu jouer pour is it has j'ai
eu qu'il avait dû se faire amputer une
jambe après il peut y avoir tellement de
fait avec nous autour de ceux de ce
personnage mythique de l'internet
extraordinaire ici tu as il est très
connu on le voit son nom à l'affairé
il est fantastique écrit si tu as
non mais les mythiques sur internet en
général et ouais c'est l'écrasent ada
ludwig je ne m'étais pas trompé avec mon
tweet le handicap 5,5 qui était couvert
très facilement par le joueur arménien
par la presse qui va relâcher la
pression
mais se faire remonter ça c'est possible
cas pour le moment ça se passe très bien
bon après le match est plié depuis on va
dire la 25e minute
il y avait déjà 3 0 mais on voyait tout
de suite que ça confirmer ce qu'on
attendait et s'allume organites au ca a
confirmé nos attentes c'est encore le 3
+ 1 re et lui dit il ya encore et encore
une heure vingt de match mais bon on
regarde je te le dis franchement on
regarde d'un oeil on regarde d'un oeil
puisque bon c'est ça n'a plus aucun
intérêt à part ça n'a plus aucun intérêt
depuis trop longtemps en fait le match
n'est pas plié depuis cinq dix minutes
il est pliée déjà depuis depuis une
heure quarante
je dirais et a même pas eu le moindre
frisson même si les frissons savais que
c'était plié mais à
mais là même la seule partie km/heure a
gagné c'est sur une erreur de
déconcentration en réalité de dike qui
domine est tellement le match qu'il a un
peu un peu baissé à baisser de rythme
mais l'a de nouveau c'est une partie où
il est pas super bien
hank
c'est une fête nous brigitte as c'est ce
que j'espérais après c'est pour ça que
je disais à voir ce que connaissons
loustics et les rumeurs les plus folles
qui peuvent circuler sur le personnage
dans c'est une bonne nouvelle fois
laissé coi ce score basset score logique
hein tu t'attendais à quoi tu
t'attendais à quoi mathieu moi j'ai
donné en début de match 98% de chances
de victoire pour pour le joueur arménien
il ya juste une trop grande différence
de niveau bien faire qu'il prend des
quatre n'a pas le choix
son cavalier a plus de gaz à effet
cavalia
kemira la défense et notre bac qui rit
mais auxerre demande à maxime 1 si on
disait que baky était pas si favorite ça
contre es c'est là c'est encore beaucoup
plus fort moi je m'attendais un peu plus
serré mais pas beaucoup plus la
martirossian sur les title tune et il
est 4e ou 5e de la saison en points
cumulés c'est c'est un très gros morceau
ouais c'est ce soir alors petit rappel
en edi 21h30 et on va peut-être essayer
de commencer à 21h le match je vais
peut-être pas le suivre jusqu'au bout
j'ai je dirais je dirais tu cherches
comme que le match était plié je leur
avais un petit peu dit déjà que arrive
de tenter des dames b5 dames 8 soit
c'est bien joué à la main entoure ses
seins il voulait faire dan des cinq
tours prend 1 dames 8 et contre attaquer
là bas mais ça c'est bien joué parce que
l'art watch 6 h 4 pouces et 1 et ça va
aller au bout pour gamer qui va qui va
enfin gagner une partie propre on va
dire un match 80 encore quelques
magouilles
allez encore dame prend 1,5 à
l'effondrement qui la gagne c'est la
haye va envoyer 5 s'est pas fait damev
6e six recettes des six à eagan la dame
incroyable même ça il a perdu km heure
là il a vraiment pas le niveau 1 il n'a
pas le niveau il fallait pas se
présenter un il fallait pas venir il
faut pas venir quand on n'a pas le
niveau petit il faut rester à la maison
et aller manger la soupe
et oui le score qui continue à enfler à
les dommages à il pouvait faire à
l'adoption
il aurait pu faire 11-0 il aurait pas
gaffer dans la partie cité 11 0 non mais
la différence de niveau est juste énorme
c'est qu'ils boxent juste trois
catégories en dessous
ce sera un cauchemar après 20 minutes de
jeu je vous ai dit c'est 25 de jeu je
vous le dis c'est ça ça va être un
calvaire pour gamer inné c'est bien pour
l'expérience au ifa tu te fais juste
simili est là
là tu te fais là la cjr il peut pas être
heureux de continuer le match il peut
pas être content heureux de se dire j'ai
encore une heure vingt à me faire
insérer le mot de votre choix
ça continue à jouer c'est même plus du
suicide c'est un viol en réunion là je
veux dire au bout d'un moment c'est
terrible c'est horrible à ce qui lui
arrive
ses stats a qu'une envie c'est de rage
quit là
c'est très humiliant de voir continuer
là pour pour lui c'est dommage
il n'y a pas le droit de quitter il peut
rien faire c'est horrible c'est horrible
c'est je sais pas je trouve que je
trouve c'est même malsain en fait un
moment donné de continuer
c'est triste quoi patrice c'est pas le
mot je sais pas quels mots employer tout
cas c'est dur c'est dur à vivre
c'est dieu c'est un moment difficile à
passer après mais bon ne pas pouvoir
arrêter sais c'est dur c'est pas un
format réjouissant
c'est pas réjouissant
martirosyan samalut on a laissé une mais
là il a levé le pied mais vu qu'il
arnaque facilement
mais surtout que je comprends pas trop
l'intérêt de continuer en fait c'est ça
le truc je n'arrive pas à comprendre
l'objectif de faire jouer jusqu'au bout
je préfère coton tige dans l'urètre que
la situation de km heure là
bah c'est psychologiquement c'est trop
dur
mais même pour martirossian c'est chiant
ouais même martyrs mais martirossian
face à une situation qui n'est pas
facile parce que d'un côté il veut
continuer à gagner l'autre côté il sent
qu'il humilie son adversaire s'est pas
toujours agréables alors je n'hésite pas
une seconde non lalalalalala seller la
situation de gamer est vraiment très
désagréable tu bouillonne à l'intérieur
creamer s'y attend forcément way devait
savoir que ce serait dur mais après tu
penses pas de faire autant autant
prendre à ce que tu vois les autres
matchs qui étaient un peu du même acabit
ils ont perdu avec 7 8 points d'écart à
la fin mais ok ils sont restés à - 4 - 5
pendant longtemps donc à - 4 - 5 tu dis
j'en gagne 2 tout d'un coup je suis là
la bombe à moins 9
ils peuvent pas arrêter n'ont cessé dans
le pays sont obligés l'organisateur
oblige à ce que à ce que ça aille
jusqu'au bout le match doit durer trois
heures trente et une peut pas racheter
ouais ça fait de la peine
ça fait de la peine pour lui après pas
non plus mort de la main il s'en
remettra
c'est parti entre quatre coups ouais
mais après tu as donné une mauvaise
image du monde qui suit machin tu étais
pts est dans une position faisant une
situation difficile pour km heure là
c'est pas une situation facile à gérer
d'ailleurs je trouve qu'il a géré assez
bien personnellement parce qu a vu son
âge il monte quand même une belle
maturité
je trouve qu'ils montrent une belle
maturité de rester en jeu voilà la
finale de pions l.perrin je dis tout de
suite ça n'a pas duré très longtemps
même pas besoin de regarder val de
l'ordi n'y a pas d'entrée pour le roi le
pion passer des noirs va parler
le roi va partir par là bas ou par
l'arrêt et à 5 b 4 qui va arriver de
l'autre côté et c'est un abandon à
wemmel acc11 victoire à une victoire il
ya dix points d'écart maintenant moi je
prétexte un kobe dans la sa place je dis
les gars zeljko vie de la joie je dois
aller faire un test
là c'est horrible parce que même aux
moments fin la mathématiquement le match
est vraiment quasi finie quoi c'est même
si tu gagnes et toutes les parties ce
qui est impossible surtout ville
scénario du match aurait quand même
match perdu je ne sais pas comment il
fait pour rester même aussi calme km
heure
je sais pas comment il fait moi je
serais tellement en train de péter un
plomb
les allemands sont quand même des gens
solides
ouais parce que là il faut vraiment faut
vraiment en avoir dans le calbute pour
continuer à jouer il reste assez
flegmatique
malgré le tarot qui se prend
mariage ou un peu en mode automatique
oui peut-être ça c'est vrai mais bon
c'est quand même un jeune garçon 1 1 15
ans vont quand même y l'adolescence et
puis un enfant mais bon
devrait changer d'entraîneur je pense
aussi à l'écho ces théories théorie
théorique théorie à fond mais c'est vrai
que ça peu après peut-être qu'il a
d'autres entraîneurs on sait pas trop
hein
après martirossian il se sentit s'est
relâchée a commencé a gaffé
donc même si je plus relâché convoi qui
joue plus tranquille il doit fatah leur
compte ils étaient de nouveau à +1 qui
doit dire si je me relâche complètement
que je commence à gaffer que je me
prends des maths en deux dans des
positions gagnantes ça va être marrant
quoi je me faire remonter donc il un peu
resserré la vis et depuis l'a pas
vraiment d'idée serré quoi alors là le
problème c'est qu'après tout reprend ses
six pions processus qui a aidé captura
food et 5
dame b 2
meiway
tout cas gros match de martirossian mais
bon s'ils jouent par ave au prochain
tour ça va être une autre paire de
manches 1 ça a été un beau match
martirossian part à mme geimer très
solide mentalement
qui ne lâche pas
nous je crois qu'on aurait tous rage
quit dans le chat non
donc
donc d'affecter des quatre mois il va
gagner
donc ça a continué ça va continuer
encore cette partie
donc ça continue ça continue adage écrit
un message quand ça continue ça joue
simon rachat que de ma souris
ff iii
il va faire 4 ème elle avait perdu un
conte martirossian et c'est un excellent
beats r1
il avait battu en demi-finale way ou en
quart de finale s'il va y avoir torah 5
peut-être pour les noirs pour empêcher à
5 à 5 voire tour prend 1,5
ok ça échange le pion à passer bon ça à
faire nul normalement mais bon il va
encore mettre le pian g5 et vu le
scénario du match il va encore pressés
qui sont les favoris la compet
martirossian
donc à avoir cadre il va y va la perdre
encore il va la perdre
c'est terrible c'est terrible il sait
faire tomber 12,1 extraordinaire
je sais plus quoi vous dire j'ai même du
mal à regarder les parties dans le sens
où c'est je suis aussi déchets autant
désespérer gamer je pense c'est ok il
répète cette variante ivars perdre bah
ouais je suis désabusé les gars c'est
sûr qu'il a lu à perdre en fête mais je
comprends pas comment le match continue
encore en fait je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il ya un moment de il n'y a pas
quelqu'un qui vient arrêter ça arrêté le
sait ça je comprends pas
c'est ça que je renvoie en fait c'est
pourquoi on ne les ya pas y'a pas bon ça
va pas le marquer à vie mais je
comprends pas pourquoi ya pas une limite
à un moment donné quand même et c'est
tout les années pareil la règle et
jamais modifié c'est déjà le deuxième
match qu'on aurait pu arrêter
il ya un autre match qui s'est mal passé
je crois que c'était le premier wii a
évoqué ce n'était pas aussi humiliant
mais on aurait pu l'arrêter après deux
heures et demie la celui-là on aurait pu
déjà l'arrêter il ya une heure de match
je ne peux pas comprendre comment
comment on peut on peut
je pensais mieux pour tout le monde mais
pour le joueur pour le public pour
l'adversaire
ouais
comme tous les matchs de carlson à
l'époque mais en fait là la règle à de
dire qu'un monde il se gagne 5 parties
d'affilée déjà tu fais un chaos déjà
serait pas mal quoi où quand tu mènes de
six points le match s'arrête ou quoi on
a on a déjà voulu faire des choses comme
ça c'est quand même pas si mal
ça permet de de mettre une limite à un
moment donné il va même tombés en
dessous de 2800 quoi si on joue en set
j'aurais déjà 4 7 0
en tout cas ils gagnent notre respect
kemer c'est déjà ça parce que j'aurais
déjà en train de taper ma souris de
gueuler agents gens pourraient plus
après on n'est peut-être pas encore bien
sûr que qu'il soit plus fort on n'est
pas sûr
il faut qu'on soit bien sûr on sait
jamais hein
voilà je vous annonce il a perdu le pion
aux 3 ça va faire ça va faire très sain
et encore heureusement que martirossian
a gaffé pour lui donner un point
heureusement
c'est vraiment bien goupillé
non mes respects pour km/heure ouais
vraiment là-dessus oui il ya eu deux
nuls bon nous après on compte les
victoires puisque c'est souvent plus le
mode de comptage en match ce que ba qui
aurait pu faire mieux
bah plus expérimentés du coup il aurait
peut-être fermer un peu la porte mais il
se serait fait écraser par martirossian
pareil
n'a laissé pas mal là ce qui fait
c'est pas mal ouais la majorité du
top-100 y prennent 3 sets à 0 contre
federer nadal djoko mais justement tu
prends trois sets zéro ça prend fin
quand c'est en grand chelem
mais quand c'est en tournant anormal atp
machin tu prends deux sets zéro ça dure
une heure 25 c'est fini tu te fais pas
massacrer non-stop pendant
en pendant des heures c'est plus facile
à vivre
c'est plus facile du coup voilà ok t'as
pris tes deux sets zéro tu as pris 6 2 6
2 ça s'arrête
tu vas pas continer puis en plus après
une fois que ça commençait tu vas pas
prendre 25 jeux à zéro quoi
tata prête à prêter trois sets et puis
c'est fini là tu prends tu prends tu
prends tu prends tu prends et s'arrête
jamais la tour 4 france et 4
défendant vlad se fait défoncer par la
food & 5 ans à gagne tout de suite
arrive à toi mais tout rejet de greffe
3f 8
ouais je pète un plomb 13,1 13,1 et
c'est pas fini
c'est il peut y avoir une adoption
peut-être ça en fait combien d'affilée
la victoire attendez il ya peut-être de
nouveaux possibilité d'adoption une
attendait 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 on a 3 game de
l'adoption les gars on a 3 game de
l'adoption
ayad options possibles à sa relance et
intérêts car là c'est l'humiliation
ultime
il en fait encore 3 et le petit km heure
on va pouvoir mettre la petite miniature
qui fait plaisir adopted c'est terrible
l'adoption c'est quand tu perds 10
parties consécutives contre le même
adversaire
c'est l'humiliation ultime faire
humiliation on nous a expliqué dans le
chat s'était pas humiliation c'était pas
le bon bout on a peut-être à peut-être à
raison peut-être à raison 14e avec les
deux nuls ouais le match est déjà
mathématiquement fini 1 c'est beau ouais
il pourrait même partir aux siens qui
est et ouest qui était vraiment pas
obligé de la perdre et en plus elle qui
l'a perdu c'était vraiment un cadeau
martirossian qui sourire est
même pas envie de voir une adoption en
tchat bon bah du coup ça donne un
intérêt la team la team entier adoption
espère que km heure face une nulle en
tout cas ce match fait pas vraiment une
pop bonne pub pour la compétition ça
c'est évident pour moi c'est évident ça
fait pas une bonne pub pour pour la
compet
mais pour le format a2 mon opinion après
mais bon ça fera pas changer le format
c'est pas la première fois qu'ils se
passe ce genre de péripéties après
martirossian way nul peut lui convenir
aussi à tout moment c'est trop long est
pas intéressant et ça fait je crois que
c'est la quatorzième compétition sur ce
format qui organisait ça fait beaucoup
pour changer d'avis hier le match était
super il y en a eu 1 qui a été bien mais
en fait tu en as tellement de nouveaux
milieux que les gens viennent même plus
voir essais organisés par thiès comme
mes choix que c'est 14e événements
qu'ils organisent sur sur ce format donc
c'est pas près de changer
derrière elle habite sprint cup non je
crois pas mais c'est sûr que niveau
format c'est peut-être un peu mieux je
parle bien j'ai écrit des mails chaque
année en fait à la fin de chaque
compétition j'ai fait des retours
pendant trois ans et à partir de la
quatrième année j'en ai eu marre et je
fais plus vraiment de retour en fait ni
haletante c'était pas mal au début
ouais mais bon comment dire s'est il ya
eu beaucoup de réussite c'est des
matches qui aurait pu se passer comme ça
en réalité on savait à l'avant ce qui
allait gagner
après moi j'ai tout fait pour essayer de
fois j'ai tout fait j'en ai un petit peu
fait j'ai pas tout fait mais j'en ai un
petit peu fait pour quand les matches
étaient un peu serré sur le contenu
pourra pour essayer de me dire que
c'était serré même si j'y croyais qu'à
moitié
en me disant bon tu va compenser un peu
serré j'essaye d'y croire même si j'y
crois pas vraiment mais je me dirais
tient peut-être que c'est le jour où il
y aura une surprise non en vrai l'idée
du format c'est vraiment ça en fait
c'est c'est réellement d'être bien sûr
que ce soit le meilleur qui gagne sans
rigoler ça s'est même pas du troll en
fait donc du coup le format il remplit
martirossian qui la force là il aurait
pu faire un nul mais il tente l'adoption
mais mais en fait oui en fait c'est même
pas du troll l'idée c'est vraiment
d'être bien sûr que ce soit le plus fort
qui gagne en fait l'argument tous les
ans pour me dire que le format de cette
était moins bien c'est qu'en fait avec
le format de cette ça donne plus de
chance qui est une surprise et en fait
l'objectif de ces tournois là c'est
d'être sûr que le meilleur gagne ou pas
sur mais disons que ça favorise le
joueur le plus fort donc en fait le
format de cette favorisant les surprises
entre guillemets il va à l'encontre de
cette idée là de se dire que le plus
fort doit gagner en fait
systématiquement
il veut dame prend 1,4 bref satie
tendent des pièges là il fait le marlou
mais du coup moi mon argument était
inverse c'est à dire que déjà les
matches plus courts c'est plus
intéressant est que en plus le fait
qu'ils aient une chance un peu supérieur
qui est des surprises ça rend la
compétition sportive plus excitantes à
suivre mais après voilà enfin chacun
chacun organise comme il veut hein
mais oui après je trouve que le nom
speech est du coup il convient pas trop
au truc parce que c'est vrai que c'est
très long c'est pas du tout il n'y a pas
de speed la dent il a filé le pion en
fait ils tentent vraiment l'adoption la
martirossian il aurait dû faire nul mais
il va la perdre
il a fait n'importe quoi il a tout donné
pour en gagner dix consécutives
il doit juste prendre un rien n'y a pas
de piège dams et roya dam des 4es
martirossian qui va juste tombé à l'est
n'a pas voulu prendre la nuit il a été
puni ça fait plaisir il y aura pas
d'adoption mais il ya toujours 11 points
d'écart c'est compliqué
ouais toute mesure qui donne du suspense
au match rajoute de l'aléatoire
exactement leur ndi et du coup quand
l'objectif est quand même de garder
l'esprit que le meilleur remporte la
partie
bah du coup et que remporte le match
après c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois que
nackaerts elle la joue et carlson la
gagne à chaque fois qu'ils carulla joué
il a gagné il faut il faut reconnaître
que ça remplit tu tues tu sais à peu
près avant la compétition qui va gagner
quoi enfin comment dire le favori est
vraiment très favoris quoi qu'ait eu 5
ça marchait patient il peut faire juste
vous prend g5 et dames pranger 5 en fait
écoutez je sais pas si on va regarder le
truc de bullet je vais peut-être appelé
à mathieu plutôt je passais encore dans
le tchat
je passais dans le chatt met à dure
comme comme match compliqué
compliqué à suivre les amis
et encore 38 de bullet mais je sais pas
si on va les faire honnêtement
honnêtement je sais pas si on va aller
faire
à présent avec une cadence 10 + 1 avant
ça permettrait d'être encore plus sûr on
pourrait jouer deux heures trente de 10
+ 1 avant du coup histoire d'être bien
sûr pas idiot à ludwig traction était
2h30 de 10 + 1 on aurait cette cadence
aussi après 1h30 de 5 + 1 une heure de 3
+ 1 et une demi-heure de bull est vrai
tu devrais proposé tu as plus de chances
avec ça que moi avec mon idée de
raccourcir le match chanson serait plus
sûr quand même surtout mon oncle 10 +0
fait partie des canons ce blitz ça
permettrait d'être plus sûr quand même
près de l'ultra bullet à la fin pour
être sûr de chez sur deux c'est sûr est
vrai pour vraiment être bien sûr et
match retour pour les matchs retour
peut-être pour être bien sûr
c'est encore le marsac se prolongent
aussi om après c'est du masochisme
après c'est du masochisme ça réveille
nos instincts les plus sombres sur de
quoi sûr que le meilleur gagne
dans le doute mais
ouais alors après il réussit un autre
système quoi c'est juste de prendre
celui qui a le plus fort et l'eau et de
le faire passer quoi tout bêtement tout
bêtement
manu que le fait de complètement enlevé
l'incertitude voire enlevée
l'incertitude pour moi ça un peu à
l'encontre de la compétition quoi enfin
en tout cas une chose est certaine c'est
que martirossian est plus fort que
km/heure en blitz ça je crois que l'on
est bien sûr le sport c'est
l'incertitude ce que le sport c'est
l'émotion et l'émotion c'est là c'est
l'incertitude en fait
c'est c'est la notion même du spectacle
sportif c'est l'émotion et l'incertitude
de la compétition du coup du coup
vouloir l'enlever en fait je trouve ça
assez aberrant mais bon c'est quand même
quelque chose de très présent dans le
milieu des échecs ce au delà de check
point comme je veux dire
bon alors est ce qui va la gagner ou pas
non mais c'est pas ça me paraît être une
évidence que le sport on regarde du
sport ce que ça génère des émotions et
les émotions sont générés par
l'incertitude du résultat comme la
finale de grand chelem hier entre entre
team et ce vieux rêve pour ceux qui ont
regardé c'est intéressant parce que
enfin le format est intéressant en fait
mais c'est justement pourquoi c'est un
beau match parce qu'on n'était pas sûr
de qui allait gagner les matches du
premier tour ou quoi quand on enfin bon
et c'est pour ça qu'ils durent moins
longtemps d'ailleurs les matchs de
premier tour parce qu'ils y gagnent 6 2
6 3 6 2 ça dure ça dure une heure c'est
c1 ça dure tête deux heures en grand
chelem mais c'est un genre de préambule
au grand combat final du coup c'est pas
directement quatre heures de match tout
le temps tout le long c'est à une
période de sélection de préambule qui
crée l'enjeu de la finale pour avoir le
climax à la fin c'est pas cessé c'est
complètement différent dans dans
l'esprit 1
tesfran eux deux du coup on va s'arrêter
là dessus les gars font ce qu on va pas
aller plus loin je vous mettre les
petits flics comme ça moi je me fais la
petite pause mais on va pas regarder à
la section bullet c'est trop
on dit points d'écart façon
mathématiquement c'est fini gamer qui en
a regagné 2 mais on avait bien vu que
haïti était vraiment plus dedans et de
toute façon dû l'être et au maximum huit
neuf parties donc je pense qu'on peut
qu'on peut ce qu'on peut se laisser là
là dessus et du coup comme ça j'en vois
le truc je me fais ma petite pause et je
reviens dans un quart d'heure pour merci
d'avoir suivi les gars je vous garde
encore une petite minute le temps de
mettre le bon titre
je vous met les petits plis comme ça moi
et comme je vous disais je vais dîner je
mange un petit truc avant
hop je veux mais les petits trucs je
vais je vais je vais changer de live du
coup je vais envoyer le raid les gars on
se retrouve on se retrouve dans quelques
secondes avec les clips d'abord et après
et après et après avec un avec le live
avec mathieu a tout de suite